bonjour à toutes et à tous je suis très
heureux de vous recevoir toutes et tous
monsieur le Président de la République
Nicolas Sarkozy mesdames et messieurs
les membres de la commission d'enquête
voilà donc arrivé la journée qui va
conclure notre travaux après près de 150
heures d'audition publique après avoir
auditionné 88
spécialistes ministres au fonctionnaires
qui ont été à un moment ou un autre
chargé des politiques énergétiques après
avoir reçu plus de 5000 pages de
documents complémentaires à analyser la
commission d'enquête visant établir les
raisons de la perte de souveraineté
d'indépendance énergique de la France
termine aujourd'hui ces cycles
d'audition
elle a le privilège d'accueillir pour la
clôture de ces auditions successivement
deux anciens présidents de la République
qui ont accepté à notre invitation de
présenter à la commission leurs analyses
et de s'entretenir avec les députés sur
les orientations de la politique
énergétique définie au cours de leur
mandats respectifs je tiens
personnellement et au nom de tous les
députés membres de la commission
d'enquête allant remercier il s'agit en
effet d'un précédent dans la procédure
des commissions d'enquête en tout cas
sous la Cinquième République cette
audition aura donc un format particulier
mais la solennité est assurée par la
simple présence de ces deux
personnalités de premier rang
cet événement s'il a pu se réaliser se
traduit de mon point de vue par trois
dispositions fondamentales dans votre
qualité monsieur le Président de la
République d'abord votre attachement à
l'institution parlementaire
l'importance que vous avez accordé à la
situation énergétique de la France dont
les implications sont à la fois sociales
économiques et géostratégiques et enfin
la reconnaissance de la légitimité de
l'intervention du Parlement dans le
domaine de la politique énergétique
notamment dans le cadre de ses activités
d'évaluation et de contrôle
monsieur le Président il vous revient
donc d'inaugurer cette procédure et
c'est un honneur pour nous de vous
accueillir à l'Assemblée nationale en
nous donnant l'occasion de vous
interroger directement
pour introduire cette audition je me
limiterai à rappeler quelques jalons qui
me semblent la justifie même si nous
avons procédé à l'audition de plusieurs
de vos anciens ministres et des
responsables qui ont servi sous votre
autorité qu'il s'agisse de Jean-Louis
Borloo Nathalie Kosciusko-Morizet
Eric Besson Catherine césarski Henri
Proglio ou Pierre Franck chevet vous
avez été le président de la République
française de 2007 à 2012 et à ce titre
vous avez notamment assurer la
présidence française de l'Union
européenne en 2008 avant l'exercice de
ce mandat de président de la République
vous aviez été ministre d'État ministre
de l'économie des finances et de
l'industrie entre autres c'est en tout
cas ce périmètre qui intéresse notre
commission
des auditions que nous avons
précédemment organisées émergent
plusieurs faits survenues ou qui se sont
déroulés au cours de vos fonctions au
ministérielles puis en tant que
président de la République je citerai
par exemple le débat sur la loi de
programme de 2005 fixant les
orientations de la politique énergétique
de la France la première du genre dans
le domaine de l'énergie la réforme du
statut d'EDF et de GDF la création en
société anonyme de RTE réseau transport
d'électricité le démarrage du chantier
de Flamanville le devenir d'Areva et
d'Alstom l'échec du marché d'Abu Dhabi
le rapport Roussely le Grenelle de
l'environnement la loi sur la nouvelle
organisation du marché de l'électricité
et la création du mécanisme de la reine
la sortie du nucléaire de l'Allemagne
Fukushima le gaz de schiste la création
du Conseil de politique nucléaire et du
comité pour les métaux stratégiques
voilà quelques éléments de contexte qui
méritent d'être rappelé ainsi que au
niveau international les différents
gaziers Russo Ukrainiens déjà le traité
de Lisbonne la crise de 2008 et celle de
la dette le grand emprunt et la revue
générale des politiques publiques
compte tenu des fonctions que vous avez
exercées je crois également
utile de relever que trois états à la
fois concurrents et partenaires dans le
domaine de l'énergie nous intéresse et
ont été abondamment cités dans nos
précédents travaux notamment l'Allemagne
la Chine et la Russie
pour terminer ce propos introductif je
ferai état des relations qui se sont
établies entre le Parlement et vont
fonctionner
de l'industrie puis votre mandat
présidentiel en effet dans l'esprit de
la réforme constitutionnelle de 2008 que
vous avez porté sur la modernisation des
institutions le Parlement a été
régulièrement informé des décisions
importantes prises dans le domaine de
l'énergie
en 2004 lorsque vous avez présenté à
l'Assemblée nationale une déclaration du
gouvernement sur la politique
énergétique en 2007 à l'occasion d'un
débat organisé à l'Assemblée sur le
Grenelle de l'environnement ou encore le
18 novembre 2008 à nouveau un débat sur
le paquet énergie climat mais il ressort
des auditions que nous avons organisées
que les députés éprouvent quelques
difficultés à connaître et donc à
comprendre les décisions issues de
compromis conclus souvent en dehors de
cette enceinte compromis européen
parfois compromis industriel
vous avez souhaité monsieur le Président
de la République privilégiez un mode
d'expression interactif je vais donc
vous céder la parole pour votre propos
d'introductif et ensuite si vous le
voulez bien nous procédons sur la base
de questions-réponses plutôt rapide et
j'en appelle donc au membre de la
commission d'enquête à après 150 heures
bien se souvenir de comment ça
fonctionne nous sommes bien là pour
interroger et échanger pas pour débattre
ça n'est pas le sens de cette enceinte
voilà merci monsieur le Président de la
République je vous je vous aide la
parole mais merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
c'était mouvant pour moi de revenir dans
cette salle que j'ai bien connue
beaucoup plus jeune
et un lieu et un mandat que j'ai
beaucoup aimé
puisque monsieur le Président vous
m'autorisez un propos liminaire
je voudrais que ce propos vous permette
de recontextualiser comme l'on dit
la situation
et d'avoir des éléments de compréhension
sur le processus de décision d'abord je
veux dire que le nucléaire est un sujet
de président de la République
pourquoi
parce que c'est un sujet d'indépendance
majeur
et parce que les décisions en matière de
nucléaire sont des décisions non pas des
cadres mais je veux dire si tu as des 4
ça décale au pluriel
le mandat de 5 ans même mandat de 7 ans
ne suffit pas je l'ai vu mais mecs les
éoliennes au large de
Pays de la Loire les éoliennes
c'est moi qui les ai décidé mais elles
ont été inaugurées non pas par mon
successeur
mais par Monsieur Macron donc c'est vous
dire le continuum
cantonucléaire il a fait l'objet d'un
consensus politique
j'ai été ministre de Monsieur Mitterrand
pendant la cohabitation
c'est pas lui qui m'a nommé mais je l'ai
eu comme précis un public il n'a jamais
mis en cause le nucléaire
donc le nucléaire c'est la première idée
c'est un sujet de président de la
République ça veut pas dire que le
président est un ingénieur ça veut pas
dire que je suis capable de vous
expliquer le processus mais c'est un
sujet qui remonte sur le bureau du
président de la République ce n'est pas
j'ai été ministre ministre d'État mais
ce n'est pas un ministre seul fut-il le
ministre de l'Industrie
qui peut décider vous voyez bien que le
s'engage trop de monde et trop l'avenir
toute ma vie
toute ma vie politique j'ai pensé que la
filière nucléaire était une chance pour
la France
je n'ai jamais changé d'avis sur ce
sujet c'est le droit d'autre d'avoir un
autre avis
et j'ai d'ailleurs été très souvent
accusé de faire partie comment dit-on du
lobby nucléaire tu me plaisenterie le
seul lobby qui existe c'est le lobby
anti-nucléaire
le lobby antinucléaire est beaucoup plus
puissant que le biducléaire puisque le
lobby anti-nucléaire bénéficiaire
pendant des années la bienveillance
médiatique
pourquoi je suis Paul nucléaire j'ai pas
changé c'est pas très original ce que je
vais dire à ce point là
mais parfois il y a des idées vraies
qui doivent être martelés
rappeler et c'est pas parce qu'elles
sont pas originales qu'elles ne sont pas
exactes on entend tellement de bêtises
j'ai toujours été pour nucléaire pour
une raison première simple c'est que
nous n'avons pas d'énergie fossile
et c'est pas parce que c'est connu que
ça doit pas être rappelé tout part de là
si nous avions des énergies fossiles
naturellement la discussion serait tout
autre
la deuxième chose
pour remplir nos objectifs
environnementaux
nous avons besoin d'une clé
les plus préoccupés
par le réchauffement climatique devait
être les premiers défenseurs du
nucléaire
la vérité elle est là
donc climatique plus vous êtes préoccupé
des hommes des questions
environnementales plus vous devez être
pour le nucléaire c'est un vrai
semblable qu'il en soit le contraire
comme si on devait opposer énergies
renouvelable l'énergie nucléaire ça n'a
aucun sens
les partisans de l'énergie de nucléaire
sont tous pour les énergies
renouvelables les partisans de l'énergie
renouvelables beaucoup sont contre
l'énergie nucléaire il doit être pour
je vous dis une chose
nous ne pourrons pas remplir nos
objectifs
environnementaux vous voyez ce que je
veux dire sur les objectifs mais en
manteau démission si nous n'avons pas
l'énergie nucléaire
troisième argument pour lequel je suis
pour le nucléaire il est moins mis en
avant mais il est absolument capital
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir
la filière nucléaire
accumulé pendant 70 ans un potentiel
extraordinaire de compétences
technologiques
qui ne sert pas que pour les nucléaires
c'est une filière qui tire derrière elle
au fond toute l'industrie
et le moindre signal de remise en
question d'une claire
remet en question une filière de
formation monsieur le Président il faut
des années pour que les meilleures
étudiants nos meilleures ingénieurs
soient formés si vous envoyez un signal
négatif sur l'industrie nucléaire vous
cassez
la formation durablement
c'est un peu comme l'affaire vous savez
eu des quotas pour les médecins
un gouvernement prend une décision de
mettre des quotas sur la formation de
médecin sur le moment la décision est
totalement inodore 10 ans après vous
rendez compte qu'il manque des médecins
parce qu'il faut 10 ans pour fonder un
médecin c'est pareil
et donc nous avions nous avons là une
filière fantastique
scientifique de haut niveau
technologique qui traînent tout le monde
vers le haut
je suis pour le nucléaire parce que de
toutes les énergies
c'est celle qui produit le moins
nuisances visuel comme sonore parce que
il faut qu'on prenne une chose il y a
pas une énergie qui soit totalement
neutre
toute forme d'énergie et justement parce
que c'est de l'énergie produit des
effets négatifs plus ou moins grands
mais il n'y a pas une énergie
disponible qui n'est pas d'effet négatif
ou indésirables et enfin je suis pour le
nucléaire parce que
c'est grâce à ça que nous avions eu
l'électricité la moins chère
voire rappeler ça
on se dit mais c'est tellement évident
comment peut-il exister des gens quand
le nucléaire parce que je viens de dire
encore une fois n'a rien d'original non
c'est incontestable c'est absolument
incontestable bon il y a pas besoin
d'être polytechnicien pour comprendre ça
alors
non seulement tu as gravé mon cas
je suis pour le nucléaire je l'ai
toujours été
mais j'ai voulu faire un petit travail
rapide je vous rassure
pour récapituler tous les aiguillages
enfin pardon tous les moments
d'aiguillages aiguillages vous comprenez
c'est ou sur votre bureau arrive une
décision vous la prenez vous la prenez
pas on peut pas faire après ça ça
m'intéresse pas l'énergie on nucléaire
c'est pas pour moi je suis un juriste
donc je comprends pas j'y touche pas
donc toute ma vie politique j'ai pris
des décisions en faveur de la filière
nucléaire toute ma vie politique
quelques furent mes fonctions
mais pire
je les ai toujours assumées publiquement
quel que soit le prix politique à payer
parce que maintenant c'est facile d'être
pour le nucléaire j'en vois qui
j'envoie qu'ils font des doubles salto
des triples salto arrière nous y
reviendrons parce que là maintenant
c'est beaucoup plus facile
mais je vais dire une première chose là
le nucléaire a fait l'objet d'une
campagne de dénigrement digne des
chasses aux sorcières du Moyen-Âge
irrationnel
mensongère
et on peut dire que les premières fêtes
news
c'est
là c'était une hystérie médiatique et
collective
qu'il reposait et je le démontrerai sur
rien
donc c'est pas tout de prendre des
décisions pour le nucléaire
fallait les assumer parce que quand vous
étiez pro nucléaire ouh là là alors là
vous étiez pas moderne vous verrez
la première décision monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur que
j'ai eu à prendre c'est en tant que
ministre d'État ministre de l'économie
des finances et de l'industrie
c'est moi qui ai fait le choix du
lancement
des établissements de la troisième
génération Diop et du choix de
Flamanville on pourrait d'ailleurs
revenir pourquoi j'ai choisi famovic
j'ai signé et choisi parce qu'il y avait
un consensus il peut venir parler j'ai
pas voulu pourquoi parce que Monsieur
Fabi c'était quand déjà
merci de dire ça mais je vais essayer
c'est vrai ou c'est pas vrai bon et à
l'époque j'avais le choix entre les deux
en tant que ministre d'État je l'avais
aucune idée je vous le demande de le
croire ce qui était important c'est
d'avoir des sources d'eau comme comme
toujours lorsqu'on installe une centrale
nucléaire faut qu'il y ait de l'eau
proche moi que ça soit flamant ville ou
mon lit non pourquoi j'étais
inflamonville parce qu'un Flamanville
ils étaient tous d'accord et capanit
Laurent Fabius était contre
mais j'ai pris cette décision et je
l'assume c'est
2004 c'est donc le démarrage des
réacteurs de la troisième génération
campagne présidentielle de 2007
peut-être vous souvenez-vous que un
animateur de télévision
qui rassemble des ONG
qui fait défiler les candidats
c'était le maître des élégances j'ai
oublié son nom
et
c'est pas le moment le plus
comment dire
le plus digne de ma vie politique parce
que je me suis prêté à ça il y avait un
tableau alors on vous posait des
questions
disons que je voulais être élu alors
j'y ai été je vais pas revenir là-dessus
j'ai été et on avait toutes les ONG tous
les gens qui pensaient bien qui étaient
modernes qui savait ce qu'il fallait
faire c'était cool
et j'ai acté
que je ferai le Grenelle de
l'environnement qui était assez nouveau
puisque ça associait les élus les
syndicats
le gouvernement
et les ONG mais j'ai dit il y a une
question que je vais sanctuariser ne
votez pas pour moi jamais je ne
remettrai en cause le nucléaire
c'est pas pour faire le malin comme tout
le monde je fais des erreurs bien sûr
mais là
en 2007 trois mois avant l'élection
présidentielle dire je sanctuariserai le
nucléaire au sens sécurisé vous
comprenez au sens je ne le remettrai pas
en cause si je suis élu devant les ONG
ce n'était pas tout à fait pareil
et j'ai acté le désaccord et d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que une ONG comme
Greenpeace qui était dirigée à l'époque
par celui qui sera le candidat des vers
la dernière élection présidentielle a
refusé d'y participer à cause de notre
désaccord sur le nucléaire il voulait
déjà casser la filière
le 12 octobre 2007 je suis élu président
le 12 octobre 2007
je vais apprendre le
sur la centrale
pour annoncer
juste une phrase je la cite la filière
nucléaire restera le cœur de la
production électrique française donc je
suis élu depuis quatre mois je vais à
panli
et je dis pas touche une clé
et je soulignais à ce moment-là que si
la France produisait deux fois moins de
gaz à effet de serre par habitant que
les autres pays d'Europe voyez pas de
mystère c'était nucléaire on pouvait pas
me dire d'un côté il faut militer contre
les gaz à effet de serre et vouloir
détruire la filière qui ont produit le
moins
ça n'a aucun sens
il y a aucune explication
aucune
et je précisais
que naturellement sur la centrale de
panique
en octobre 2016 que nous allions
développer le renouvelable
mais
que le renouvelable serait un complément
en aucun cas une substitution parce que
ceux qui expliquent que le renouvelable
peut-être une substitution monte
immante ce n'est pas vrai ce n'est pas
possible je donnerai des exemples donc
je n'ai jamais dit je n'ai jamais pensé
qu'il fallait soit nucléaire soit le
renouvelable il faut le nucléaire et le
renouvelable en complément pas en
substitution
3 juillet 2008 je récidive
là c'est plus grave
puisque je suis au Creusot
et j'annonce la construction
d'un second réacteur nucléaire de
nouvelles génération donc j'assume être
responsable
des deux EPR pas de 1 2 et pourquoi je
le fais
parce que remettez-vous dans le contexte
très simple à comprendre nous étions en
juillet 2008 devant une flambée des prix
des hydrocarbures
le prix des hydrocarbures explose
donc naturellement la réaction normale
de bon sens
consiste à dire on va avoir besoin
d'énergie l'énergie
fossile devient de plus en plus cher ça
explose renforçant nos capacités
nucléaires et je décide donc d'un
second site EPR
les centrales de la troisième génération
dont je propose
qu'elles soient installées à Paris
je vais plus loin puisque la ministre
des universités de la recherche à
l'époque very Pécresse qui était ma
ministre
j'annonce publiquement les archives
peuvent en témoigner que nous aurons
besoin de 1200 ingénieurs nucléaires de
plus par an
à partir de 2010 parce que naturellement
si vous faites des centrales vous
augmentez le nombre d'ingénieurs dont
vous avez besoin ça crée des emplois si
vous fermez des centrales vous le
diminuez c'est assez simple à comprendre
vous pouvez pas faire des centrales sans
avoir les ingénieurs et donc nous
décidons de muscler la filière pour
avoir plus d'ingénieurs nucléaires
je rappelle que le projet de panli a été
arrêté par François Hollande
pourquoi personne n'en sait rien
puis repris monsieur le président
nous avons perdu 12 ans
là c'est pas un problème d'ingénieur
c'est pas un problème de moteur c'est
pas un problème de d'organisation c'est
pas du tout ça
nous avons perdu 12 ans ce qu'on dit
j'avais pris la décision le site était
choisi tout était possible enfin je veux
dire alors il y a des taux de problèmes
techniques je reviendrai mais là c'est
clair pourquoi revenir là-dessus
le 6 février 2009
comme j'ai de la suite dans les idées
j'ai dit tiens c'est bien les centrales
nucléaires je vais retourner et cette
fois-ci je vais à ville
nous avions connu la grande crise
financière de 2008
donc
on était en plein dans la crise et
j'annonce mon intention de faire du
nucléaire le moteur de la reprise
économique
oui j'ai la suite dans les idées je
pense que c'est un atout économique je
voudrais vous donner juste une chose
on avait un déficit très important du
commerce extérieur
un opère produit 12 milliards 12
milliards de kilomètres
par an
dans mon idée
ça permettait d'avoir 600 millions
d'excédents à l'export
facilement
parce que je voulais que la France non
seulement soit autonome énergétiquement
mais puis s'exporter
et dans un souci d'équilibre j'avais
cette formule ce n'est pas parce que la
France est championne du nucléaire
qu'elle doit être la lanterne rouge des
renouvelables
et j'annonçais notre soutien au
développement d'une véritable filière du
renouvelable
je précisais sous forme d'avertissement
il est très difficile de recréer de la
compétence nucléaire dans un pays qui
n'investirait plus dans cette
technologie la succession de périodes
d'investissement massif et de périodes
d'arrêt
peut-être destructeur pour une filière
d'une telle intensité technologique je
vous dis une chose
les signaux désastreux politique
idéologique qui ont été envoyés
ont découragé les meilleurs de nos
étudiants d'aller dans la filière
nucléaire
parce que contrairement à ce qu'on dit
la Parole du politique ça compte
et contrairement à ce qu'on dit l'action
commence par les mots les mantes un sens
surtout en France
on a l'amour des mots
et quand vous les politiques vous avez
peur du nucléaire vous envoyez un signal
que vous allez détruire cette filière
parce que
l'arrêter c'est la détruire
c'est comme si vous m'expliquer
que l'Atlantique l'océan Indien et le
Pacifique il y a pas de marée
avec le nucléaire vous avancez vous
reculez vous vivez vous mourrez c'est ça
la filière technique de haute intensité
le 3 mai 2011
je retourne dans une centrale nucléaire
je les ai pas tous faites mais bon
nombre cette fois-ci je vais à
Gravelines
et je dis nous allons continuer à
investir dans le nucléaire pour
développer la production d'électricité
monsieur le Président excusez-moi cette
déclaration est importante parce qu'elle
souvient quelques semaines après
Fukushima
quelques semaines avait après Fukushima
aggraveine je dis nous allons continuer
investir dans le nucléaire je provoque
un tollé
pas d'applaudissement
je vais venir et je précise d'ailleurs
que sans le nucléaire ce qui est vrai le
prix de l'électricité serait multiplié
par 4 parce que tous ces beaux esprits
qui ont fait les malins sur 70 ans de
compétences
d'ingénieurs et d'ouvriers parce qu'il
faut voir dans une centrale le
dévouement des gens la qualité des gens
je parle pas simplement des ingénieurs
et des concepteurs je parle de ceux qui
qui gère au quotidien ils aiment leur
métier c'est des gens extraordinaires
mes propos donc suscitent l'indignation
des écolos comme des socialistes
qui ne faisaient pas mystère de leur
volonté de freiner et quand je dis
freiner je suis gentil
brutalement le développement de la
filière nucléaire
dans le même temps j'annonçais qu'après
Fukushima
je décidais de lancer un audit de
sécurité sur tous les équipements
nucléaires monsieur président pas
simplement les centrales
tous les équipements nucléaires sans
exception c'est-à-dire qu'en plus de la
révision décennale vous savez que
l'Autorité de sûreté fait à peu près 700
contrôles par an
et toutes les centrales passent au grand
contrôle tous les 10 ans après Fukushima
la France
a décidé par ma voix
d'engager un audit en plus de la
décennale surtout les centrales
nucléaires et toutes les installations
nucléaires
je concluais d'ailleurs que c'était
étrange de voir tous ces gens qui
disaient nucléaires et dangereux et qui
refusait qu'on investisse dans nucléaire
alors ça c'est un truc c'est une ça
serait risible si ce n'était pas si
grave mais les mêmes les mêmes qui
disaient nucléaire est dangereux refuser
de mettre un centime dans le nucléaire
par définition si vous voulez comme les
mesures de sécurité augmente puisqu'on a
le retour d'expérience de tous les
accidents les nouvelles centrales sont
plus sûrs que les anciennes on ne sait
pas très intelligent de dire quelque
chose comme ça mais c'est les mêmes qui
mettaient en garde faussement l'opinion
publique contre les dangers du nucléaire
refusaient dans une logique incroyable
incohérence de mettre un centime dans le
nucléaire c'est logique ça
c'est cohérent là d'ailleurs mesdames et
messieurs excusez moi mais s'il
nucléaire est dangereux pourquoi fermer
que Fessenheim
tomber sur la tête pour faire une chose
comme ça
pourquoi s'il nucléaire est dangereux
admettons allez je me mets de l'autre
côté le nucléaire dangereux ferme tout
pourquoi faut sauver que les Alsaciens
enfin pardon ce Président c'est une
démagogie d'accord ok normal c'est un
vrai semblable mais c'est un vrai
semblable de dire une chose pareille
et le pire c'est que tout ceci pouvait
être dit sans provoquer d'autoller dans
les médias au contraire je vais venir
le 7 juin 2011 j'espère pas être trop
long mais j'essaie d'être très précis et
naturellement tout ce que je dis peut
être vérifié il y a pas de problème
s'agit pas de j'aime pas me relire mes
propres déclarations mais je crois qu'il
faut être précis demande une commission
d'enquête
le 7 juin 2011 la décision des Allemands
de fermer leur centrale
il y a un entretien téléphonique entre
la chancelière Merkel et moi qui est
comment dit-on franc
ou je dis à Angela qui est une personne
pour qui j'ai du respect de l'admiration
avec qui j'ai aimé travailler mais nous
avons eu un désaccord
elle annonce qu'elle va fermer si mon
souvenir est exact les 9 centrales de
Bavière
mais là qu'est-ce qui se passe
ça va pas
et me dit mon frère Nicolas tu as pas vu
Fukushima
mais je dis d'où vient le tsunami en
Bavière
mais
c'était affreux
affreux bon alors on pourrait me dire et
je l'accepte que je n'ai pas
publiquement
appuyer sur le désaccord je l'accepte
moi j'ai toujours pensé que le couple
franco-allemand c'est important et qu'il
faut pas trop jouer avec ça vous savez
entre Louis XIV et 1945 on s'est
affronté tous les 30 ans
on peut
ces triper entre italien et français
c'est aucune importance on s'aime
sur le coup franco-allemand
il faut considérer que la qui de la
réconciliation de la paix est tellement
précieux
donc je n'ai pas c'est vrai
portez le
désaccord violemment publiquement je me
suis contenté de dire bon si les
Allemands arrêtent leur centrale ils
auront besoin d'électricité on va leur
vendre
parce que nous fermons pas
et je précise publiquement je vous
demande de l'entendre je dis après
Fukushima
chef d'État doit garder son sang-froid
point il n'y aura donc aucune fermeture
en France m'entendez
aucune
parenthèse quand les Allemands ont fermé
leur
centrale ils ont ouvert toutes les
centrales à charbon je le dis aux
écologistes qui balance leur particules
sur Paris comme vous le savez que les
vents dominants on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir de grandes recherches on sait
parfaitement ça donc je voudrais vous
dire que cette décision quand même d'un
cynisme fort on ferme les centrales au
prétexte à risque de tsunami en Bavière
on rouvre les centrales à charbon mais
ne croyez pas que les centrales à
charbon polluent que l'Allemagne
ça a été démontré depuis bien longtemps
que les pollutions des centrales à
charbon viennent jusqu'à Paris
c'est pas gentil de dire ça mais
vérifiez c'est intéressant
je rappelle qu'on est quand même en
Europe
enfin le 25 novembre 2011 je me suis dit
je n'ai pas visité la centrale nucléaire
de Pierrelatte allons-y
je vais donc sur la centrale de
Pierrelatte
et je déclare la réduction de la part de
l'énergie nucléaire provoquera une vague
massive de délocalisation
ce sera un cataclysme économique et une
folie on peut pas dire qu'on n'a pas mis
en garde
je peux tout entendre tout comprendre
c'est pas parce que c'est ma conviction
qu'il est bonne mais personne ne peut
dire
qu'on n'a pas mis en garde
ah non on n'a pas compris on n'a pas vu
non non non non non non non non il y a
eu un débat
il y a des responsables politiques qui
ont dit ce qui pensait faut pas mettre
tout le monde dans le même panier c'est
trop facile
il y a des gens qui ont assumé les
responsabilités
j'ai dit ça serait une folie un
mouvement de délocalisation massif
je visais l'accord PS Europe Écologie de
novembre 2011 quand même prévoyait enfin
les montres un sens
24 fermetures sur 58 réacteurs
pour réduire de 74 à 50% la part du
nucléaire dans la production électrique
des françaises mais je veux dire à votre
commission je ne sais pas si vous l'avez
noté sans doute compétent comme vous
l'êtes qu'il était prévu
en plus
la fermeture de l'installation de
retraitement de La Hague pourquoi
mais pourquoi
quelle est cette affaire
est prévue la fermeture de la production
de combustibles de Marcoule
donc on voulait fermer l'installation de
retraitement et l'installation de
production on voulait tuer la filière
j'ai vu on parle de fermetures des
réacteurs non non non non non
et ça nous ramenait où ça nous ramener à
la décision de 98 je crois de Lionel
Jospin pour faire plaisir à domicile
de faire mes super Phénix qui faisait du
retraitement
une conscience
il y a ceux qui ont voulu détruire la
filière
et il y a ceux qui l'ont promis
et c'est très important dans une
démocratie bien sûr qu'on souligne les
erreurs des uns comme des autres moi le
premier naturellement
mais quand on a dit juste contre le
courant bien alors il faut que chacun le
courage de reconnaître et de faire la
différence c'est pas la même chose c'est
pas la même chose et je regrette qu'on
ne parle pas de cette affaire de de
Marcoule et de lag parce que là elle me
semble plus
illustrative en quelque sorte monsieur
le Président Monsieur le rapporteur de
la volonté de détruire la filière
parce que les mêmes disent en même temps
ah oui mais vous savez on aura un
problème de je reviendrai de d'uranium
ah oui mais mon ami si on a un problème
d'uranium tu le dis avec ta main droite
et qu'avec ta main gauche tu fermes
Marco
c'est quoi ça
ça veut dire quoi ça
alors
à citer
trois déclarations dans un florilège
effrayant
mais trois déclarations intéressantes
Monsieur Hollande
à la suite de ma déclaration de novembre
2011 à la centrale de Pierrelatte je
cite en défendant le nucléaire
Nicolas Sarkozy monte qu'il est un homme
du passé car il défend un modèle
économique dépassé
m'entendez
le nucléaire est un modèle économique
dépassé en l'occurrence l'effet en
parler
je suis pas sûr que le nucléaire soit
pas plus dépassé que d'autres
il y a mieux
madame Aubry
premiers secrétaire du Parti socialiste
avec le nucléaire
Nicolas Sarkozy et le président du
siècle dernier
et enfin il va joli
que j'ai peu l'habitude de citer
candidate écologique à la présidentielle
entendait cela entendez cela et
naturellement vous vérifierez
défendre le nucléaire c'est s'accrocher
à la ligne Maginot ou au minitel
mesdames et messieurs quel que soit vos
convictions je m'en excuse si je blesse
telle ou telle ici
c'est grave
une telle
incompréhension
défendre le nucléaire c'est défendre la
ligne Maginot immunitaire
voilà ce qui pouvait être dit au
Moyen-Âge
en 2011
ça se passe de commentaires et si
j'avais un commentaire à faire je dirais
ça fait honte
non pas des comptes nucléaires je peux
comprendre de dire ça
j'ai répondu monsieur le Président ce
que je crois toujours aujourd'hui
le nucléaire n'est ni de droite ni de
gauche il est l'intérêt supérieur de la
France c'est pas une déclaration que je
fais aujourd'hui
c'est une déclaration que j'ai fait
en 2011
et je n'ai quasiment terminé
à l'époque mes contradicteurs
faisaient deux contre sens historiques
terribles terribles monsieur le
président
le premier
la demande d'électricité allait baisser
alors là
comment
pourquoi
est-ce que c'est en France est-ce que
c'est en Europe est-ce que c'est sur le
monde
dans le même temps au monde possède
quand je suis né il y avait 2 milliards
et demi d'habitants sur la planète je
suis encore très jeune on essaie cette
meilleure et demi cette émission par 3
dans 30 ans on sera
plus de 8 milliards et à la fin du
siècle certains disent on aura dépassé
les 10 milliards
et la demande d'électricité va baisser
on a assisté à des choses effrayantes
j'ai entendu un animateur de télévision
devenu ministre
dire dans la même journée le matin
formidable dans 15 ans on aura fermé la
moitié du parc nucléaire français
mais dans 15 ans la totalité du parc
automobile sera électricité l'ami tu
récoltes l'électricité toi
ça se récolte ça se voit seul
c'est ce qui pose non mais on peut
entendre non mais comprenez-moi bien
c'est je ne fais pas
comment un déni d'opinion ou
moi je plutôt ouvert et je crois que le
débat mais ça ça dire dire cela que la
demande d'électricité allait baisser ça
veut dire que ceux qui disent ça ne
savent pas que l'électricité se produit
par du pétrole portugais
alors deuxième contre sens
c'est l'éolien qui serait l'énergie de
remplacement joue aussi juste un exemple
si vous voulez remplacer les 24
réacteurs nucléaires premiers à la
disparition
faut 30 000
ça représente 115 milliards
d'investissement
c'est un détail
qu'on soit pour ou contre le détail donc
on va fermer 24 réacteurs qui existent
qui ne posent aucun problème dans le
voisinage n'a aucun problème en général
les gens défendent leur centrale je
parle sous le contrôle des élus qui vous
même monsieur le Président puisque vous
êtes dans circonscription je crois bien
Fessenheim
j'ai aucune mobilisation des voisins ou
des élus bon évidemment on va donc
enfermer 24
m 30 000 éoliennes sur le territoire
français et investir 115 milliards dans
les éoliennes
je le dis alors que
sous mon quinquennat
la puisse la capacité éolienne française
a été multipliée par 8 puisque le parc
éolien le parc
photovoltanique français a été porté de
2 mégawatts à 1700 MW
enfin j'en aurai là c'était vraiment
terminé 9 février 2012 sur le site de
Fessenheim
où je me suis rendu à deux reprises
parce que ces gens ont été montré du
doigt c'est irrespectueux à l'endroit
des travailleurs de cette centrale et
des élus de la
je sais pas si vous imaginez que pendant
des années ils ont été montrés du doigt
en disant ils sont dangereux
je vous le dis devant cette commission
d'enquête
c'est un mensonge
j'ai annoncé le 9 février que j'avais eu
sur mon bureau le rapport
des autorités indépendantes à la fois
sur la visite décennale et sur la visite
post Fukushima le réacteur numéro 1
j'avais pas le sur le 2 mais le réacteur
numéro 1 était parfaitement sûr et
l'Autorité de sûreté lui donnait 10 ans
de plus
Fessenheim c'est 70% de l'électricité
toute la classe
ces 400 millions de bénéfices pour EDF
mais vous vous rendez compte au moment
où
EDF et besoin d'être Capelli
recapitalisé auteur du milliard on a
décidé de fermer une centrale sur
qui rapportait 400 millions d'euros qui
fournissaient l'électricité d'une grande
région industrielle entre autres comme
l'Alsace
70%
change aucune vous m'entendez aucune
aucune raison valable
et quand on me dit que ça a l'air d'être
remplacé par flamant ville on savait
parfaitement bien à ce moment-là que le
chantier de le père de Flamanville avait
du retard donc c'est pas vrai la
discussion elle était pas là
voilà
voilà ce qui s'est passé
vouloir détruire la filière nucléaire
française
c'est trahir l'intérêt national français
merci
bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président pour ce propos liminaire déjà
très complet j'aurais deux questions
pour ensuite faire circuler la parole
très vite
je vais vous les poser en même temps la
première concerne la place du nucléaire
dans les discussions que vous avez pu
avoir au niveau européen notamment à
l'occasion de la présidence française de
l'Union européenne en 2008 on voit bien
aujourd'hui que le débat est très
récurrent sur la taxonomie sur la place
du nucléaire par exemple pour produire
de l'hydrogène qu'elle était cette
situation en 2008 et au cours de votre
quinquennat et enfin une deuxième
question qui est elle aussi est tournée
vers vers l'international
il y a eu un certain nombre de
tentatives de vente d'outils nucléaires
à l'étranger qui ont échoué avec
on l'a vu au cours de nos auditions des
difficultés entre DF et arriva comment
est-ce que vous avez traité ce sujet là
merci monsieur le Président bon au
moment où j'ai été président de l'Europe
j'ai aimé président de
parce que
j'ai eu la chance contrairement à ce
qu'on a dit d'être président période de
crise
par quoi c'est une chance parce que la
élargit les procédures vous pouvez vous
échapper spécialement à Bruxelles et à
Strasbourg
de la même liste technocratique car la
crise provoque un tel choc tellurique
que le politique reprend
toute son utilité j'ai aimé
passionnément
nous avions à l'époque assez peu parlé
d'énergie monsieur le Président parce
que je vous rappelle qu'au moment où
j'ai fait la présidence de l'Europe
monsieur Poutine a eu la mauvaise idée
d'envahir la Géorgie
les chars russes étaient à 25 km de BBC
je m'y suis rendu et à Moscou et à
bellissi pour faire sortir les Russes de
Géorgie
ce qui a pris une certaine énergie
est-ce qu'il y a
bloqué toute ma présidence puisque vous
savez ces six mois
nous étions au mois d'août
il y a eu une grande débat pour savoir
si j'avais le droit d'y aller sans
mandat moi je voulais pas demander je
voulais être libre j'ai dit vous voterez
et puis deuxièmement on avait les
conséquences monsieur président n'a
crise financière et je vous garantis que
les débats autour de la table du conseil
à ce moment-là c'était pas du tout des
débats sur le nucléaire ou pas le
nucléaire j'y reviendrai quand même
c'était des débats sur comment régule
comment on évite que tout explose
c'est ça que l'on a eu moi j'étais six
mois précédent donc je ne vous dirai pas
que j'ai mené des combats numériques
pour défendre le nucléaire parce que
c'est pas vrai mais c'est pas vrai pas
grâce à moi c'est pas vrai parce que
c'était pas entre la Géorgie et la crise
financière c'était cela pour le reste
l'Europe
n'a jamais été je veux dire dans sa
techno structure pro-nucléaire
et un certain nombre de nos amis
et rivaux
aurait été parfaitement content
de pouvoir
si un peu l'avantage exceptionnel pour
une fois que la France avait un avantage
que représentait le nucléaire
et donc pour faire inscrire le nucléaire
comme une énergie propre mais c'est un
combat que vous n'imaginez même pas
mais même pas
donc il y a à la fois de la jalousie de
la concurrence je peux le comprendre
après tout nous aussi
donc tous les gouvernements français qui
ont été pour nucléaire
n'ont jamais bénéficié de soutien de la
techno structure européenne
qui pourtant devrait aurait dû dire mais
tant mieux la France c'est
le deuxième quand il y avait les angles
troisième moteur économique de la fusée
européenne tant mieux qu'ils aient cette
avantage faisant profiter les autres ça
jamais été leur état d'esprit et nous
quiions pour le nucléaire on était à la
fois attaqué
pour ces raisons là par l'Europe et
médiatiquement parce que le lobby
antinucléaire avait des relais
médiatiques mais d'une puissance
fantastique fantastique
bon voilà pour l'Europe
sur les sur le les marchés extérieurs
vous savez monsieur le Président parfois
on gagne par son père
ce serait tellement bien qu'on gagne
comme la politique
c'est tellement bien qu'on gagne à tous
les coups peut-être pas d'ailleurs parce
que si on gagnait tous les coups on
aurait moins de plaisir aux Français on
a du plaisir vous aussi pour des élus
c'est parce que vous regardez tous ceux
qui ont été élus on est bon donc mais je
vais venir sur Abu Dhabi j'étais très
déçu par Abou j'étais très déçu
de mon point de vue mais ça c'est c'est
vraiment ce que j'ai ressenti je peux me
tromper de mon point de vue si on a
perdu Abu Dhabi c'est parce que
Abu Dhabi avait à l'époque 10 millions
d'habitants ils en ont 12
et le Pr
était un peu surdimensionné
si vous voulez entre la centrale
électrique de base sans mépris et le Pr
pour un pays de 10 millions d'habitants
je pense qu'on n'avait pas de chance
j'ajoute que les Coréens ont promis des
choses et ça c'est montré par la suite
puisque c'est les Coréens qui ont gagné
qui n'ont pas pu tenir
mais nous on arrivait avec un quelque
chose d'un peu surdimensionné et deux
des mesures de sécurité
entre nous qui n'avait rien à voir avec
ce que les coréen avait vendu je ne dis
pas que c'était dangereux les Coréens
dis ça je pense que c'est pas dû aux
problèmes arriva EDF ça n'a rien de
simplifié vous parfaitement raison sur
faire dire ça mais je pense que c'est un
problème de produits sur étagère
pour le reste
les centrales EPR en Chine fonctionne
elles ont
coûté elles ont mis enfin ils ont mis
le double de temps prévu je crois qu'ils
ont mis 6 ou 7 ans pour le réacteur
il leur a coûté plus cher puisqu'il a
coûté une dizaine de milliards d'euros
mais ça fonctionne et on a gagné
la fin d'un dossier
et l'Angleterre c'est pas mon époque moi
j'étais tout à fait pour ça fonctionne
donc le produit EPR
et je relisais le rapport de jean-marsin
Falls qui avait qui a été demandé je
crois pas Bruno Le Maire mais qui est
intéressant et qui dit lui-même c'est
pas le produit au père qui est en cause
d'autres questions sans doute mais je
pense que voilà pour l'export je pense
qu'on a on aurait eu une centrale
adaptée à des pays de 10 millions
on avait plus de chance
merci monsieur le Président je vous
remercie monsieur le Président de la
République d'être venu devant notre
commission d'enquête d'avoir déjà pu
faire un propos liminaire aussi précis
et d'avoir déjà apporté c'est très
nombreuses réponses je voudrais vous
poser une première question parce que
vous avez parlé de l'énergie nucléaire
comme une industrie et avec toutes les
conséquences que ça en terme de
politique industrielle vous avez rappelé
que vous aviez signé le pacte de Nicolas
Hulot et dans ce pacte un des
engagements était celui de créer un vice
mini service Premier ministre en charge
de l'écologie qui avait aussi le
portefeuille énergétique et vous avez
tenu cet engagement et l'année suivante
en 2008 vous avez en créant la direction
générale de l'énergie et du climat
rattacher pour la première fois dans
notre histoire institutionnelle
l'énergie à la direction du climat et
puis en 2010 le choix a été fait
j'imagine votre choix de ramener
l'énergie au ministère de l'Industrie
est-ce que c'est un pur choix
administratif ou est-ce qu'il y a
derrière cette évolution une question
prof onde d'organisation de l'État et
d'importance que l'énergie soit
rattachée à l'industrie
oui c'est un choix politique que
j'assume on peut être contre bon je nous
étions face à une vague de
délocalisation moi j'ai toujours aimé
l'industrie
j'ai toujours passé mon temps aller dans
les usines je n'ai jamais cru à une
économie exclusivement de service parce
que s'il y a plus d'industrie les
services se mettent au service de qui
absurde
et donc je me suis rendu compte que la
question de la fourniture d'électricité
pour nos filières Saint-Gobain et autres
étaient centrale et que grâce au
nucléaire on pouvait gagner en
compétitivité ce qu'on perdait en
compétitivité avec le poids de nos
charges sociales je suis pas en train de
remettre en cause sociale mais si vous
voulez on a des charges sociales il y a
un modèle social beaucoup plus coûte que
les autres
on avait cette avantage d'une énergie
moins coûteuse que les autres
mais c'était vraiment un choix pour
l'industrie deuxièmement quand nous
avons fait le plan d'avenir vous savez
le grand emprunt un emprunte alors
est-ce qu'il est de 36 milliards d'euros
moi j'ai annoncé 36 milliards d'euros
Bercy passé derrière même quand on est
président de la République si vous
vendent des fraises pour des tomates et
c'est similaire de Rome avec l'effet de
levier vous allez voir bon bref vous
promettez 36 milliards à l'arrivée voyez
25 milliards vous n'avez pas compris
vous dépassez les saisons mais il y a un
effet de levier on comprend pas tout si
ce n'est que ils ont gardé l'argent
après tout c'est leur rôle bon mais dans
le plan d'avenir
j'ai prévu un milliard pour la recherche
nucléaire le projet Astrid parce
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde parle des
centrales de la troisième génération
mais par pitié ne faisons pas l'erreur
de la deuxième à la troisième préparant
la quatrième je vois pas pourquoi Astrid
est arrêté ça n'a aucun sens il faut
continuer je veux dire que la recherche
pour Astrid pour la quatrième génération
certes pour la troisième sert même pour
la deuxième et dans le cadre du grand
emprunt j'avais dit également
un euro pour le renouvelable un euro
pour le nucléaire
juste un petit mot parce qu'il y a
s moi je suis consciencieux
il m'arrive de voir ce que les gens
disent
il y a une petite phrase qui m'a pas
bien plu
il va pas bien plus
sur le déficit d'entretien des centrales
EDF qu'est-ce qui permet de dire ça
qu'est-ce qui permet de dire ça
je vois les chiffres
c'est faux
l'investissement d'EDF dans les
centrales étaient triplés
à ma période je ne serai pas dire que
EDF
à brader l'entretien des centrales
d'ailleurs si EDF avait bradé
l'entretien des centrales
comme dit l'autre je m'énerve pas
j'explique
l'Autorité de sûreté n'aurait pas telle
n'aurait-elle pas protesté
y a-t-il un réacteur fermé à mon époque
donc ça joue pas comme ça parce que
c'est pas exact je suis tout à fait prêt
à répondre toutes les questions mais ça
vous ne direz pas c'est pas exact
et si je comparais je peux pas être
cruel
la situation de DF que Monsieur Proglio
la présidait et après
je suis prêt à faire la comparaison je
suis pas sûr qu'on perdra
non donc les choses soient claires je ne
mets pas en cause le président de la
République actuelle parce que
fashionheim depuis 5 ans était fermé je
n'ai pas les éléments qui me permettent
de dire c'était possible d'arrêter la
fermeture ou pas je ne les ai pas
monsieur donc je ne le dirai pas vous
voyez ce que je veux dire parce que
quand on sait pas on dit pas
on peut on peut discuter je n'ai pas ces
éléments donc je ne peux pas le dire je
peux comprendre ça a été fermé pendant 5
ans ça faisait 5 ans qu'on m'a traquait
en disant ils sont dangereux ils sont
vieux allez jeter les poubelle je ne
sais pas si vous pouvez le faire mais je
ne laisserai pas dire que EDF à l'époque
de Monsieur poglio que j'ai nommé
notre n'est pas les centrales nucléaires
ce n'est pas vrai
c'était pas votre question mais ce qui
est un peu ma réponse
je me serais pas permis monsieur le
Président
justement très rapidement de dernière
question je l'ai pose séparément pour la
bonne lisibilité de nos travaux vous
avez été aux responsabilités lorsqu'elle
a été décidé la construction d'un nouvel
EPR et ensuite vous étiez président de
la République pendant une période clé et
je voudrais juste rappeler ces chiffres
pour qu'on les aient en tête en 2006 le
projet de l'EPR LEPR est estimé un coup
de 3 milliards pour une mise en service
en 2012 en 2010 pour un coup de 5
milliards avec une mise en service en
2014 et en 2012 à la fin du mandat à 8
milliards et demi pour une mise en
service en 2017 j'imagine que vous avez
suivi ce dossier de prêt vous avez dit
au début que le nucléaire était une
affaire de président de la République
quels explications avez-vous et comment
est-ce que vous vous traduisez
industriellement politiquement cette
question de l'EPR
je peux répondre la directement parce
que c'est vraiment un sujet
difficilement
inutile de vous dire Monsieur
l'emporteur que j'ai pas d'explications
techniques c'est d'une complication
atroce mais si vous regardez les choses
donc flamant ville les travaux
commencent en 2007
on nous annonce l'ouverture de
Flamanville pour 2024
ça fera 17 ans
pour un coup final estimé à 13 milliards
si j'en juge on peut discuter si c'est
12-13 mais si j'en juge les chiffres de
défense
pour moi
encore une fois j'ai relu le rapport de
Martin folles qui est très intéressant
il ne remet pas en cause la conception
du moteur du moteur et d'ailleurs il a
raison parce que tie Chan c'est les
mêmes
donc allez-vous m'expliquer si le moteur
est trop compliqué si ça marche pas
pourquoi ça marche la taille Chan
et ça marcherait pas aflamment ville
enfin
aucun sens puisque eux les Chinois n'ont
pas fait
je crois donc
qu'il y a un premier problème
c'est que les conditions de sûreté je
dis de sûreté pas de sécurité la sûreté
si tout ce qui se passe à l'intérieur la
sécurité ce qui se passe autour en
France
sont sans doute et tant mieux les plus
fortes du monde
prenez un exemple vous savez que
maintenant enfin maintenant les opère
ont une double coque sur le puisque si
un problème nucléaire ça fond et donc il
faut mettre un ravier extrêmement
puissant dessous pour pas que ça pénètre
la nappe phréatique et il faut mettre
une coque au-dessus pour pas que ça
parte dans les impôts maintenant on fait
une double coque
pour un EPR la double coque doit
résister
au choc d'un avion qui se poserait sur
le chapeau de la centrale
bon je ne pense pas qu'en Chine je dis
pas qu'en Chine ils sont dangereuse
c'est pas du tout ce que je dis mais les
choses sont les mêmes je pense qu'il y a
entre le moment on a décidé Flamanville
et le moment sera ouvert les conditions
de sécurité ont changé vous prenez un
chantier comme le chantier de flamant
ville si Mo souvenirs sont exacts vous
avez plus de 3000 ingénieurs sur le site
donc
je veux dire que
nous avons perdu de la compétence
en matière de construction de de
centrale puisque rien n'avait été
construit depuis la centrale de Civaux
si vous comparez que les Chinois je ne
suis pas un admirateur absolu de
monsieur le Président chier mais
ils ont construit en permanence des
centrales
donc c'est un peu si vous voulez quand
vous êtes dans une dans un hôpital on
vous dit que un hôpital maternité qui
fait ou l'obstétricien fait moins de 300
accouchements à l'année ça devient
dangereux parce qu'il perd la main
je pense que ce qui s'est passé aussi
entre entre
cette centrale
la dernière
que nous avons construit et Flamanville
on a perdu du du de la substance
troisièmement
comme vous le savez taille Chan a
commencé deux ans après la Finlande
et flamant ville ils ont donc bénéficié
du retour d'expérience de ce qu'on a mal
fait
troisièmement certainement il y a des
faiblesses sur l'organisation de EDF
pour suivre le chantier un je ne je veux
pas l'exonérer mais je vous demande de
réfléchir à ça aussi non pas d'être
indulgent pour les ingénieurs mais de
comprendre qu'on est au top du top de la
technologie
on est à l'avant-garde là
c'est pas un truc qu'on peut faire avec
la certitude vous voyez ce que je veux
dire on est dans quelque chose dans 50
ans ceux qui nous succéderont vous êtes
très jeune en tout cas moi je ne serai
plus là ce qui vous ne succéderons
diront c'est fantastique ce qu'ils ont
fait comme EPR ça continue à produire
l'électricité bon
mais au début d'un processus on n'est
pas à l'époque de Joliot-Curie on n'est
pas à l'époque de la pile Zoé qui est
précieusement conservé à Clamart donc il
faut accepter l'idée que quand on fait
un saut technologique de cette
complexité ça peut pas être en obsession
en ordonnée ce qui ne veut pas dire
monsieur le rapporteur qui a pas eu des
erreurs que tout n'a pas été fait comme
ça devrait être fait qui a payé des
bagarres à l'intérieur et puis en plus
quand le discours ambiant après c'est de
dire le nucléaire on va le fermer le
nucléaire on va l'arrêter les gens qui
travaillent sur la pointure et qui
attendent sans permanence c'est pas non
plus un encouragement
et quand t'entend vous ferme ton lit qui
est le la jumelle en terme de centrale
voilà pour le reste je me remets au
rapport de Jean-Martin fols qui me
paraît équilibré et capable de dire
beaucoup plus de choses que moi parce
que j'ai dit que le nucléaire c'était du
niveau de président de la République
mais ça veut pas dire que je comprends
pardon le chantier de Flamanville
j'ai été peut-être 10 fois dans une
centrale nucléaire 10 fois on m'a
expliqué quand on est dans la centrale
bon je prenais un air concentré je me
concentrais à fond mais au bout de cinq
minutes j'étais largué voilà pour vous
dire les les connaissais suffisamment
pour prendre des décisions mais le
processus c'est monstrueusement
compliqué
je vous remercie une dernière question
monsieur le Président qui a beaucoup
occupé nos travaux c'est bien sûr la
question des règles européennes et le
fait que en 2010 la loi nomme était
adoptée qui a porté ouverture du marché
de l'électricité qui a initié le
dispositif de l'arène qui a fait l'objet
de nombreuses discussions dans notre
commission d'enquête et qui a fait
évoluer le statut des centrales
hydroélectriques statue qui dont la
question est toujours pas résolue et
l'ensemble de ces éléments au vu des
auditions que nous avons menées et des
réponses que nous avons eu semble avoir
plutôt affaibli la situation de
l'opérateur en charge de nos centrales
et avoir affaibli de manière générale
notre capacité à investir y compris dans
les centrales hydroélectriques quel est
votre point de vue là dessus et sans
anachronisme quelle était la situation à
l'époque qui a conduit ses décisions là
non je vais bien sûr y répondre monsieur
le rapporteur mais enfin Loiseau
ça n'a rien à voir et que le
démantèlement de la filière nucléaire
moi je veux bien on peut être pour ou
contre je vais je vais en parler je vais
pas fuir c'est pas mon genre mais enfin
on va pas me dire que l'accord PS écolo
c'est à cause de la Noiseau c'est
plaisanterie il y a un choix idéologique
absurde qui a été fait
qui est là rien à voir je vais répondre
mais quand bien même on n'est pas pour
la noix de
alors on peut dire la noyau affaiblit
EDF
c'est pas une raison vous avez la grippe
on vous emmène une autre chose sur la
tête ça va mieux comme ça là vous
produisez 100 d'énergie nucléaire on
vous dit vous serez pas dur à 50 et en
plus vous voyez ce que je veux dire
cet argument était absolument inéquable
alors j'ai eu à travailler de près sur
EDF à deux reprises monsieur le
rapporteur un pour le statut
et je m'en souviens
je m'en souviens parce que
ce qui est sympathique c'est que vous
avez pas besoin de parler pour savoir
quelle famille vous êtes bon alors et je
le dis ça moi non plus moi non plus moi
je suis de ma famille bon donc mais je
vais même vous dire mieux
peut-être je vais vous faire plaisir
j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec un homme
que j'apprécie et
qui s'appelle Frédéric Humbrecht
et qui était le patron de la CGT
énergie vrai ou pas bon et nous avons eu
ce truc qui nous est tombé sur le dos
qui était le changement de statut de DF
puisque
Bruxelles indiquait que des f pouvait
accéder au marché sans aucun problème
puisque elle avait la garantie de l'État
puisqu'elle appartenait à l'état et que
il fallait changer statut j'ai dû le
faire ce qui avait provoqué j'étais à la
centrale de shinod c'était nénette je
crois mais dans une sortie vivante
c'était même assez sympathique
finalement on a pu le faire sans trop de
grammes c'était ma première intervention
j'ai pas eu le choix
nous faisons partie de l'Europe je suis
un Européen convaincu
l'Europe était persuadée qu'il fallait
ouvrir à la concurrence et d'ailleurs
moi je suis plus pour la concurrence que
pour le monopole parce que je pense qu'à
chaque fois que il y a un monopole ça
sera ni en catastrophe
s'agissant de la loi noum je rappelle
que l'origine de l'ouverture à la
concurrence des marchés de l'énergie
se trouve
dans les directives européennes de ce
qu'on appelle à l'époque le paquet
énergie quelle date 1996
ce paquet énergie a été transposé dans
la législation française
par 30 textes le paquet énergie
30 textes
c'est contexte qui ont ouvert le marché
à la concurrence ont été pris entre 2000
et 2001
qui était premier ministre
on est en cohabitation thé monsieur
Jospin
il faut que chacun vous savez dans la
vie il y a des dates il y a des faits
embêtant mais c'est comme ça
et c'est à ça que c'est à l'histoire il
faut pas hésiter à se replonger dans les
livres parce que si on sait pas d'où on
vient on sait pas où on va
et la loi l'homme
c'est le résultat très exactement de ça
couronné excusez du peu
excusez du peu monsieur rapporteur par
le sommet de Barcelone
semaine Barcelone qui
se tient
quelques mois avant
que Jacques Chirac ne gagne l'élection
que moi je rentre au gouvernement en
2002 voilà c'est ça l'histoire de la
guanome alors après la loi de l'homme a
été et qui a conséquence de cette
libéralisation et moi je vais pas vous
faire la démagogie de dire que je suis
contre je suis assez pour la concurrence
même pour les trains
même pour les trains parce que la
concurrence ça va booster un peu la SNCF
je pense que la concurrence ça booste
aussi et on en a besoin Air France et
que la concurrence à l'époque à l'époque
moi j'avais EDF arriva et Suez
qui opéra le nucléaire en Belgique
mettez-vous à ma place de président
j'allais pas casser l'un pour l'autre
fallait faire attention à cela on avait
plein de champions maintenant on en a
plus c'est mieux non je crois pas
à l'époque quand on a décidé peintville
la grande bagarre c'est de savoir est-ce
que c'est EDF ou est-ce que c'est
chouette
on avait de la richesse bon alors moi
j'ai le souvenir que quand Jean-Louis
Borloo m'a proposé de fixer
à 40 puis à 42 hauts de 2 euros vous
savez le prix de de la reine à l'époque
la polémique c'était plutôt que je
défendais EDF au détriment des
consommateurs
mais regardez c'était pareil pour le
téléphone
il y avait trois licences
il y avait
qui était pas orange j'étais français
l'école il y avait
Bouygues et puis il y avait SFR
quand j'ai décidé de la quatrième
licence je suis fâché avec beaucoup de
gens croyez moi ce qui l'ont eu l'ont
oublié mais ceux qui ont vu un nouveau
concurrent ils savent quel était le
coupable c'est aussi l'ouverture à la
concurrence aujourd'hui vous allez
quatre opérateurs téléphoniques qui
parmi vous reviendrez sur les quatre qui
me dirait qui oserait me dire
aujourd'hui que c'est un tort d'avoir
quatre à mon avis les quatre gagnent de
l'argent
les trois m'expliquaient que si je
faisais un quatrième il mourrait
ça faisait de la peine de les voir
d'ailleurs si émue non à l'arrivée 15
ans après
personne n'est mort tout le monde gagne
de l'argent il y a quatrième opérateur
et les prix du téléphone ont été divisés
par trois par quatre
donc moi je j'assume que je suis pour
l'ouverture à la concurrence
et l'idée qu'on pouvait garder EDF
reine du monde assis sur le nucléaire
payé par les impôts des Français sans
concurrence et sans qu'aucun fournisseur
peut venir c'est une idée que je
n'approuve pas alors je dis pas que
l'homme c'est bien je dis pas que les
conditions n'ont pas changé tout
simplement discuter mais au niveau de
président de la République où j'étais
autorisément à rester sur l'autoroute et
pas prendre le départementale parce que
c'est quand vous êtes Président vous
êtes au niveau de l'autoroute si vous
rentrez dans le départemental vous
perdez bon cette ouverture à la
concurrence par principe ne me choque
pas
j'accepte tout à fait le débat avec
d'autres qui avait cinq choix toutes
c'est un débat tout à fait à la
différence du nucléaire ce débat là il
est il est intellectuel il est
intéressant de lire parfaitement
légitime bien ceux qui sont pour la
concurrence comme moi il y a ceux qui ne
sont pas pour d'accord voilà et donc
j'ai accepté la loi note qui nous
mettait en conformité avec nos
obligations
européennes faut-il la chanter la
changer peut-être aucun problème mais
sur le raisonnement de base d'ouverture
à la concurrence préférable
au monopole bon moi qui n'ai jamais été
un admirateur de Staline des communistes
du modèle chinois tout le reste je vous
dis je suis pour l'ouverture de la
concurrence
merci monsieur le Président on va faire
passer la parole par ordre d'importance
des groupes politiques au sein de notre
assemblée comme il est coutume et puis
après un premier tour de parole ensuite
on poursuivra avec les autres députés
qui membres de la commission qui
souhaite poser des questions
alors pour commencer pour le groupe
Renaissance qui n'apprend madame
bouziref
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Sarkozy bien écoutez vous avez
répondu à la plupart des questions
et vous avez mentionné tout d'abord
effectivement que le nucléaire
appartient à est un domaine qui
appartient au régalien et éminemment et
même au président de la République alors
aussi cela peut-il expliquer qui est eu
quelques arrière pensée politique
et que certains et saisit des occasions
effectivement comme la catastrophe de
Fukushima
c'est peut-être ce qu'a fait Madame
Merkel c'est peut-être ce qui aussi
je dirais justifie
la position qui a été prise après dans
le quinquennat de François Hollande
donc je voulais savoir quand même quel
était l'état d'esprit en France
justement après Fukushima parce que
l'opinion publique a quand même
son importance aussi dans les décisions
que prennent le politique
et je voulais revenir après juste sur
une
une mention vous avez faite que vous
vous visiez peut-être des excédents de
production d'électricité dans l'esprit
de d'exporter c'était l'électricité qui
effectivement permet de d'apporter de la
richesse
et comment on peut concilier
effectivement viser des excédents de
production d'électricité avec la reine
en même temps qui qui est un système qui
qui bénéficie peut-être un peu moins
effectivement à la société qui produit
cette électricité donc en l'occurrence
c'était EDF
merci Madame pour vos questions d'abord
les arrière-pensées politiques j'en ai
eu
c'est pas ça qui me saute au contraire
qu'un homme ou une femme veut être élu
il part pour gagner pas pour perdre
attention on en parle pas derrière pensé
politique là on parle de la destruction
d'une filière majeure de d'intérêt
général ça n'a rien à voir
si vous voulez dire parfois il y a de la
démagogie bien sûr et ce que je l'ai été
moi-même certainement madame
la politique je l'ai dans le sang donc
j'ai aimé la politique
je trouve que c'est très noble et je
serai toujours moi du côté de ceux qui
choisissent l'engagement par rapport à
ceux qui sont dans la rivière les pas
croisés qui s'engagent sur rien
moi j'aime pas les experts
un combattant donc mais vous pouvez pas
dire que ça c'est des arrières quand
c'est politique c'est autre chose
on est sur du dur
pareil pour l'armée française
mais pas sinon vous n'avez pas fait une
commission d'enquête quand même on n'en
quête pas sur une une petite
arrière-pensée politique ou une petite
blague non non non non
l'opinion publique mais madame la
grandeur d'un politique c'est justement
d'être contre l'opinion publique un
moment vous savez la politique c'est la
conviction c'est pas la séduction
peut venir de la conviction elle ne met
jamais le préalable
c'est très important de comprendre ça
c'est dans cet ordre ça se passe on peut
séduire parce qu'on convain
C mais si on met la séduction avant la
conviction c'est un problème donc
sur le Fukushima
on a menti à l'opinion publique en
disant que Fukushima est un accident
nucléaire c'est faux
madame les chiffres sont brutaux
savez-vous combien eu de victimes
Fukushima
du raz-de-marée
combien y a-t-il eu de victimes c'est
les rapports des Nations Unies
par radiation 1
malheureusement je suis pas en train
d'expliquer que
un
Fukushima c'est un tremblement de terre
de force 9 qui ne s'était jamais produit
au Japon j'étais premier visiteur
étranger au Japon dix jours après
Fukushima tout le monde disait il faut
pas y aller il y a des radios il y a de
la radioactivité bon je me souviens
avoir traversé Tokyo il y avait pas une
voiture
il y avait pas un avion sur le tarmac de
l'aéroport de Tokyo
c'est un tsunami
de force 9 le 11 mars 2011
la vague était 30 mètres de hauteur
la vague est rentrée
10 km à l'intérieur des terres
et j'ai vu un endroit moi-même ou la
vague a été à 42 mètres
et la vague
a explosé les groupes électrogènes de
secours de de la centrale qui sont
tombés en panne
ce qui a conduit à une destruction du
système de de
refroidissement et à la fusion du du
réacteur qui a tenu il y a eu des
émanations il y a des émotions les
autorités internationales ont mis
l'accident au niveau 7
comme comme Tchernobyl mais les
conséquences sont rien à voir tchernoby
c'est un accident nucléaire
Fukushima c'est une catastrophe
d'ailleurs il y a eu pour 12 milliards
de travaux après Fukushima sur les
centrales françaises puisqu'on a mis des
groupes
diesel 2 de secours on a mis des
réserves d'ultime enfin bref on a on a
changé ça mais au Japon comme en France
sténystérie alors au Japon on peut le
comprendre parce qu'ils étaient sonnés
j'ai vu le premier ministre qui m'a dit
je peux plus tenir on va arrêter de
nucléaire je dis je t'en supplie prend
un peu de temps je comprends mais
l'émotion mais en France
donc c'était ça le
l'état d'esprit alors après sur la reine
et surtout ça
c'est éminemment complexe on ne peut pas
garder un modèle avec
EDF assis sur toutes les centrales
nucléaires françaises qui ne vend pas
son énergie aux autres oui le système
et c'est pas l'Union soviétique ici on
peut pas marcher comme ça alors je
reconnais que il y a un côté un peu
kafkaïen qui consiste à produire
l'électricité et avant de je reconnais
bien moi-même je me suis posé la
question
mais la politique et c'est intéressant
ce que disait le président tout à
l'heure dans son propos luminaire s'il
me permet les compromis
ah oui
et oui
mais la politique c'est pas écouté
ça serait tellement simple c'est
interpréter
parce que quand vous allez dans la rue
vous les députés si vous écoutez ce que
vous disent les gens parfois ils vous
disent rouge j'y pense vert il pense
noir pour interpréter
c'est ça la noblesse de la politique
c'est de transformer des contradictions
en énergie positive pour trouver une
voie c'est bien ça qui est le plus
difficile moi j'ai toujours voulu parler
à la France qui travaille
mais comment expliquer
et convaincre les les ouvriers que on
est plus avec eux en récompensant le
travail on peut sans davantage en
faisant le mérite mais c'est ça la
politique alors oui mais quel est
l'autre système madame on garde EDF
assis sur le trésor des 58 réacteurs
et on interdit à tous nos concurrents
étrangers de venir vendre l'électricité
mais comment ça marche comment vous
faites fonctionner ce truc là
oui bah comme bravo oui oui attends non
ça a changé c'est qu'on est dans le
marché unique ça avançait que maintenant
nous si les autres concurrents madame
faisait ça pour nous on hurlerait à la
mort
on hurlerait à la mort bon c'est c'est
je dis pas que c'est simple je ne le dis
pas mais la politique c'est ça et là on
est en Europe moi je suis très attaché
et j'ai dirigé
l'Europe du cette chance et répondu aux
questions du Parlement européen c'est
fantastique 750 parlementaire 22 langues
et ça fonctionne
bon oui quand même quand même ça
fonctionne pas en guerre
et quand je vois l'état des Britanniques
aujourd'hui c'est quand même on a envie
mais c'est ce que disait le Président
c'est aussi des compromis madame enfin
pardon je réponds à votre question
j'essaie de le faire au niveau j'étais
ça veut pas dire que je dois pas
descendre c'est pas du tout ça mais
comment on réagit comment on pense quand
on est chef de l'État qu'on a personne
au-dessus mais qu'on a beaucoup de gens
en dessous avec les Français et il faut
trouver un équilibre
et c'est cet équilibre que j'ai trouvé
mais jamais bien volontiers qu'il est
pas définitif qui n'est pas parfait mais
j'explique le raisonnement
de la même façon quand j'ai fait les 62
ans j'ai toujours dit que c'était pas
une une réforme définitive je ne crois
plus à la réforme définitive qui vaut
pour 50 ans bon et bien on a fait le nom
voilà le raisonnement je crois que le
raisonnement il se tient il est assez
cohérent il conforme à nos obligations
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on peut le changer
oui j'ai pas de de problème avec ça mais
dire que les problèmes de DF viennent de
là non ça j'accepte pas voilà
merci excusez-moi merci monsieur le
Président alors pour le groupe
rassemblement national
le président de la République Sarkozy
merci pour vos propos
et vos premières réponses assez directes
rapidement voici trois premières
questions je voudrais revenir sur les
chèques de 2009 d'Abou Dhabi vous
déclarez que c'est parce que notre offre
n'était pas adaptée et trop ambitieuse
pourtant la puissance de la centrale
coréenne est proche de celle que nous
proposions le projet français était bien
parti pour être pour être sélectionné
mais pour certains observateurs vous le
savez le principal problème du projet
français aura été la rivalité entre les
différentes entreprises françaises et le
manque d'unité en matière nucléaire
pas eu des difficultés à faire
travailler les géants français ensemble
n'avez-vous pas eu parfois l'impression
que nous faisions preuve de naïveté pour
dire ça comme ça là où les Chinois
américains russes japonais avancent de
manière disons un peu plus coordonnée
vous allez dire au sujet de la décision
de Lionel Jospin d'arrêter super Phénix
que c'est une folie pour reprendre vos
mots vous auriez pu relancer le projet
pourquoi ne pas l'avoir fait
ensuite et je vais m'arrêter là pour
l'instant parce que je pense que les
collègues ont d'autres d'autres
questions sur la question des ressources
humaines on constate depuis une
vingtaine d'années
que la filière du nucléaire peine à
recruter en cause le manque de
perspective de la filière ainsi que son
image de nombreux savoir-faire ne sont
plus maîtrisés des compétences sont
perdus qu'avez-vous fait pour remédier à
ce problème
merci monsieur le député bon
moi j'étais très déçu je suis au Abu
Dhabi
et je l'ai vécu de près parce que
Abu Dhabi
Mohamed Bensaid le qui était à l'époque
prince héritier on a fait beaucoup de
choses puisque on a fait le Louvre sous
une idée de Jacques Chirac puisque j'ai
ouvert la base militaire qui est
toujours là personne ne l'a fermé
puisqu'elle a la Sorbonne
je sais ce que m'a dit Mohamed Benzaid à
l'époque
que les Coréens étaient 35% moins cher
et que leur système était plus adapté
est-ce que c'était la vérité de ce
député ou pas je sais pas
si un jour vous êtes responsabilités
vous verrez qu'on gagne pas toujours
comme pour les élections
parfois on perd
est-ce que les rivalités existaient vous
avez raison oui est-ce que ça m'agaçait
à ça oui
et pas simplement là et pas simplement
là
mais si je me posais la question est-ce
que j'aurais pu
changer les choses plutôt parce qu'on
avait encore une fois arriva EDF Suez
peut-être c'est pas difficile c'est pas
facile il fait quoi que je décapite
arriva
à nos versions étaient là j'ai fini par
la renvoyer
plus tard quand la situation était
devenue impossible je rajoute Alstom et
je pense que s'il y a quelqu'un sur
notre scène politique qui a fait pour
Alstom je crois être celui-là
et j'ai pas beaucoup apprécié la
disparition d'Alstom donc oui il y a eu
des rivalités vous avez raison
mais mettez-vous dans la tête du
président de la République allez
mettez-vous président de la République
vous avez EDF
vous avez Areva
avoir des rêves c'est bien c'est
important
il y en a beaucoup qui ont rêvé
il y a beaucoup qui ont rêvé il y a et
que c'est bon vous avez EDF arriva Suez
qu'est-ce que vous faites
quoi
vous dites toi tu restes à la maison
mais arriva et EDF devait travailler
ensemble l'un était pour le carénage
l'eau était pour le moteur devait je
deviens président de la République
c'est dure 5 ans
je vais faire du mécano
chaque fois qu'un politique fait du
mécano comme ça ça se termine comment
donc oui les rivalités vous avez raison
oui ça n'a rien arrangé vous avez raison
mais si c'était la seule solution pour
qu'on gagne en Chine pourquoi on gagne
enfin
d'être un petit peu net
la même organisation était en place
elle nous permet de gagner en Chine nous
permet de gagner en Finlande
donc si c'était ça la raison pourquoi on
gagne là-bas et on perd là ça n'a pas de
sens donc je vous donne le point il y
avait de la désorganisation de la
rivalité
peut-être tu aurais pu faire autrement
je sais pas comment
si ce n'est se séparer d'une des
personnes bon
en tout cas je l'ai pas fait pour dire
vous me dites chez les Chinois et les
Russes c'est plus coordonné je vous
confirme
mais j'avais pas compris que c'était le
système que vous admiriez mais peut-être
que je me trompe
oui les américains ils ont une chose les
Américains c'est pas pareil monsieur je
vous dire les Américains vous savez
pourquoi ils gagnent ils ont gagné des
marchés nous on a dit
ça s'appelle nucléaire Ombrella
voilà
et les américains ils ont gagné le
marché sur l'Europe parce qu'ils ont la
puissance militaire et que c'était vendu
avec donc je vous fais pas de l'injure
de ne pas suivre les affaires étrangères
ou les étranges averses vous croyez que
les Américaines parce qu'ils ont mieux
organisés non c'est Michael gagne parce
que c'est la première armée du monde
et que quand ils vendent leurs
équipements militaires ou civils il y a
le paquet qui vient avec bon et en plus
ils ont la bonne et mondiale ça aide
voilà donc ne croyez pas que c'est une
question d'organisation vous pouvez
copier l'organisation des Américains
vous verrez que vous n'avez pas la
puissance qui est derrière eux pourquoi
j'ai pas relancé super Phénix c'est
impossible parce que pour le coup quand
vous arrêtez une filière je rappelle
que cette filière était arrêtée depuis
près de 10 ans
la relancer comme ça
j'ai mis de l'argent sur la quatrième
génération j'ai pas mis de l'argent sur
le retraitement
des déchets nucléaires d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui encore il y a un grand sujet
sur l'uranium
et il faut me semble-t-il de toute
urgence
nous mettre sur cette question de de
l'approvisionnement
qui est aujourd'hui diversifiée
puisqu’un de nos pays fournisseurs de
nos livres plus de 20% mais on peut
faire de la recherche je crois que c'est
l'uranium sans
38 ou 158
138 qui est produit par nos centrales et
qui semble-t-il on pourrait le
réutiliser
voilà et puis sur le sur les formations
je vous l'ai dit la ministre des
universités a eu l'instruction de
développer une filière de formation
scientifique c'est un problème qui ne
concerne d'ailleurs pas colnucléaire qui
concerne la France on fait trop dans la
philosophie trop dans la sociologie trop
dans les études sociales et pas assez
dans les mathématiques et les sciences
c'est pas nouveau mais le nucléaire en
est le cœur
merci bien monsieur le Président de la
République je crois que j'ai
la triste responsabilité de vous
annoncer que vous faites l'objet d'un
boycott des députés de la France
insoumise je n'en vois pas ce matin j'ai
passé la parole à un début du super
j'ai entendu avec beaucoup de sympathie
monsieur le Président de la République
merci pour vos propos liminaires qui ont
été
très bien posés sur le plan calendaire
par rapport donc à votre fonction de
président moi je voudrais revenir sur
sur la loi norme et la reine donc fin
d'année 2010 vous faites voter la loi de
l'homme et donc qui met en place la
reine je voudrais rappeler que à ce
moment-là
nous sommes exportateurs d'électricité
et que de rentrer sur le marché de la
concurrence et que le prix du dernier
neutrons produits et de 39 euros le
mégawatts et que dans la loi normes donc
la reine est à 42 euros le mégawatt
depuis donc les choses ont changé et que
cette arène dans la loi c'est clairement
écrit dans la loi et pilotable tant sur
les volumes à ce moment-là nous
produisons 400 TW
et il est proposé d'inscrire sans
terawatt donc de mise en concurrence
donc dans la reine étant sur le prix par
décret donc ministériel
le
aujourd'hui nous produisons 240
terawatts au niveau du nucléaire vous
l'avez bien très bien expliqué on sent
bien que après votre mandat les
présidents de la République et les choix
politiques ont été autres en matière de
défense du nucléaire et du maintien de
cette production nucléaire qui nous
amène aujourd'hui effectivement à être
donc importateur d'électricité d'avoir
perdu notre souveraineté électrique
quand nous avons auditionné l'ucrément
le dernier PDG des DDF il nous dit que
aujourd'hui avec les travaux de grands
carénage qui a eu donc qui permettent de
justifier de pouvoir donc
par décret augmenter le tarif de la
reine et je voudrais quand même qu'on
puisse avoir votre avis éclairer sur la
chose et par rapport à ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui lucrément nous
dit que le coût pour EDF c'est 135 euros
du mégawatt ça voudrait dire que
logiquement
par décret nous devrions faire passer la
reine
à 135 euros du mégawatt à la demande des
DF nous avons au mois de juillet dernier
prix donc la décision donc à l'Assemblée
sur la loi du pouvoir d'achat de faire
passer le tarif de la reine à 46,50 € du
mégawatt et on nous dit que sur donc
directive européenne c'est tout
simplement pas possible de de
l'appliquer ce tarif donc vous avez été
président de l'Europe moi ce que je
voudrais savoir c'est
comment aujourd'hui on voit bien les
difficultés que ça pose à l'ensemble de
notre économie française ce tarif de
l'électricité ce tarif réglementé
européen est-ce que il faut continuer
sur l'arène vraiment la piloter et le
faire passer à 135 euros comme nous le
dit le PDG des
DDF est-ce que
c'est de stopper la reine provisoirement
et est-ce que l'idée serait aussi pour
sauver économiquement nos entreprises
d'avoir un tarif réglementé national
plutôt que de rester sur ce marché
concurrentiel européen dans l'instant
merci de votre réponse
c'est une très très bonne question c'est
un sujet extraordinairement difficile
pourquoi parce que quand tu arrives sur
le bureau du président de la République
quand tu arrivais
la question de l'augmentation des tarifs
je me trouvais au milieu d'une
contradiction
je voulais pas qu'on augmente trop les
tarifs
je vous le dis je vous réponds très
sincèrement parce que si vous augmentez
les tarifs
vous tuez une partie de votre industrie
et vous diminuer le pouvoir d'achat des
Français
nous avons connu la crise de 2008 des
subprimes mais nous avons connu après
2010 la crise de la dette européenne
donc à chaque fois je disais au ministre
enfin pas trop fort parce que
il y a le pouvoir d'achat il y a la
récession je ne vous rappelle pas le
contexte économique mais en même temps
je président en répondant ça j'ai très
bien que vous affaiblissez dans ce cas
là l'opérateur
puisque l'opérateur il veut des tarifs
le plus élevé possible
non pas au prix du coup de production
mais au prix du coût de production plus
l'amortissement des investissements
parce que le coup de production quand
j'entends dans le débat elle coûte
production c'est 10 il faut qu'il
analyse mais non c'est comme pour les
médicaments parce qu'il faut financer la
recherche il faut le financer tout ce
qui va avec donc il y a une
contradiction
et il y a une contradiction et je peux
prendre tous ceux qui sont autour de la
table confrontés à cette situation c'est
pas facile et même ceux qui n'y sont pas
si un jour ils étaient au pouvoir est-ce
qu'on favorise l'entreprise et son
développement ou le pouvoir d'achat ou
les tarifs des
usines ou des entreprises
donc nous on a essayé s'en sortir
peut-être avec une cote mal taillée
qui ne ruinait pas EDF
mais qui nous mettait pas avec 14%
d'augmentation
premier point deuxième point vous avez
prononcé un mot et moi j'ai aimé votre
question dialoguer avec vous là dessus
tarif réglementé
j'aime pas ça
parce que ça se termine toujours mal
parce que le tarif réglementé vous
refusez des augmentations parce que
tarif réglementé c'est pas pour faire
des augmentations c'est pour les éviter
je connais assez peu de tarifs
réglementés pour faire payer beaucoup
plus cher je connais beaucoup de tarifs
réglementés pour dire il y a une
élection oh il y a un rendez-vous il y a
ceci c'est comme ça bon ça se termine
toujours mal
Pascal à la fin il faut recapitaliser
les entreprises il faut payer la facture
moi je crois au marché
quand ils sont calmes au marché régulé
c'est pas du tout au marché
sans règles
donc est-ce quel est le niveau faut-il
aujourd'hui je n'en sais rien je n'ai
pas les éléments du dossier on peut dire
ça
mais je vous fais une confidence c'est
pourquoi un moment donné j'avais pensé à
ouverture du capital d'EDF
je l'ai pas fait donc
ce que je dis c'est pour le plaisir de
la discussion et de la joute parce que
je me disais de choses
l'État n'est pas un bon actionnaire au
sens qui n'a jamais les disponibilités
pour aider investir et de dans le fond
une entreprise privée il y a la loi de
l'offre et la demande région donc
c'était j'écarisé je l'ai pas fait donc
bon mais je pense que dans les années à
venir le problème de l'ouverture du
capital de DF sera clairement posée
alors je vois bien qu'avec les centrales
nucléaires il y a un problème d'intérêt
national mais on peut aussi trouver des
formules là dessus mais je crois que les
différentes forces politiques doivent
réfléchir me semble-t-il à comment
sortir du système seulement de la
régulation ou de la dérive la science
pour trouver quelque chose qui va être
notre grand champion français
en capacité de conquérir des marchés
étrangers de redevenir exportateur voilà
moi je préfère vous répondre sur la
stratégie sur les questions d'avenir que
sur le sol domaine brim sur le président
de savoir à quel niveau il faut le
mettre parce que je pense que le système
tel qu'il est n'est pas ne sera pas
possible pour l'avenir si nous voulons
avoir des grands championnats
énergétiques qui ne peuvent pas être
gérés de manière excusez-moi
administrative sans remettre en cause
administration
merci monsieur le Président je me
permets une petite incursion dans le
dans le déroulé normal des questions
pour laisser la parole au groupe Geder
avec Monsieur jumelles qui m'a indiqué
qu'il a une contrainte monsieur jumelles
merci monsieur le Président de la
République j'ai beaucoup aimé la
première partie de votre démonstration
celle où vous réaffirmez la constance de
votre engagement sur le mixte votre
conviction sincère et non remis en cause
pour la filière nucléaire
et y compris
l'argument dont sur la priorité des
priorités de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique incompatible
avec l'absence de du nucléaire dans le
mixte
mais je je dois vous considérer que j'ai
beaucoup moins aimé la deuxième partie
parce qu'il y a une forme de
contradiction et c'est le sens de ma
question à réaffirmer et je crois que
vous le dites en sincérité le rôle
stratégique de la politique énergétique
l'industrie des industries le rôle
déterminant de la politique énergétique
pour la souveraineté notre pays
l'intérêt suprême qu'elle représente y
compris au point de justifier que les
décisions stratégiques soient prises
dans le bureau du président de la
République
et de l'autre côté
avoir commis des actes vous les avez
rappelé en sincérité 2006 le
transformation du statut de l'entreprise
je m'en souviens aussi
[Musique]
et puis les dérégulations successives
nous sommes quand même dans une période
où
l'explosion du prix de l'énergie qui
fragilise non pas seulement nos artisans
boulangers mais l'industrie réelle
milite pour une reprise en main de la
puissance publique milite pour
décorer les le prix du gaz dans la
construction du prix de l'électricité y
compris
en réduisant la légende aux Allemands de
ce point de vue là milite pour non pas
la caricature d'une nation administrée à
la soviétique
mais pour que ce bien commun de première
nécessité ne soit pas traitée comme une
marchandise comme les autres vous l'avez
dit vous-même ou ne fabrique pas des
Barbapapa lorsqu'on produit de l'énergie
nucléaire et donc je veux
sans nourrir beaucoup d'illusions sur la
capacité que j'aurais à vous convaincre
que le libéralisme ne produit pas
toujours
les résultats qui le prétendaient
commettre mais attirer votre attention
sur est-ce que la situation
d'aujourd'hui
préoccupante d'affaiblissement de la
filière d'affaiblissement de nos
savoir-faire de risque même en plein
hiver de rupture d'approvisionnement
vous avez vu que nous avons nous a
menacé cette
hypothèse de délestage
ne milit pas pour tout simplement voilà
on est où ta stratège un état qui prend
soin un état qui régule un état qui
préserve les intérêts de la nation un
état qui prend soin de son industrie et
au bout du compte un état qui dit à
l'Europe que la liberté la
libéralisation libre et faussée parce
que la reine ça malformation congénitale
c'est pas d'avoir tenté de concilier
pris pour l'usager et rémunération pour
EDF ça malformation congénitale c'est
d'avoir permis la vente à des marchands
de savonnette des marchandsses de soleil
qui ne produisent rien et qui ont vendu
de l'électricité acheter à bas coût à
EDF sur le dos au bout du compte de
notre fleuron et de la nation voilà le
sens de mon interpellation conforme à ma
sensibilité politique et c'est plutôt
bien d'assumer sa cohérence et ses
convictions jusqu'au bout mais qui je
crois est connecté aux préoccupations et
à la situation grave que nous traversons
dans le domaine de la politique
énergétique
bon
mais moi j'aime bien votre façon de
poser le de poser le problème parce que
bon vous me demandez de pas vous
caricaturer vous avez raison vous faites
pareil pour moi bon vous n'êtes pas
soviétique je suis pas libéralomaniaque
je suis pas Madeleine
et et échou suffisamment longtemps dans
ma majorité on m'a critiqué pour ne pas
être assez libéral pour ne pas
maintenant être accusé ultime non mais
restons là dessus c'est intéressant
l'État est stratégique qui n'est pas
gestionnaire
ça c'est une première chose et vous
devez avec l'honnêteté qui est la vôtre
faire la différence entre la décision
stratégique pour l'état de ce substituer
au marché en investissant en argent que
le marché mettrait pas pour démarrer une
filière et la gestion de cette filière
c'est pas la même chose oui le marché
il aurait pas fait le nucléaire
c'est l'état
mais une fois que nucléaire est installé
c'est l'État qu'il a détruit
confère ce que j'ai raconté donc l'état
est dans son rôle on peut se retrouver
pour démarrer une filière vous voyez
stratégique qui ne démarrera pas
spontanément avec des capitaux privés
moi je pense qu'une fois que la fille
est démarrée qu'une fois que c'est lancé
qu'une fois qu'on a des géants il vaut
mieux
le secteur privé que l'État qui est un
mauvais actionnaire
et qui n'est pas en mesure gérer ça
deuxièmement pour faire baisser les prix
vous dites à les prix je les régule non
pour faire baisser les prix vous
augmentez la production
si l'offre est plus importante que la
demande les prix baisse
et le débat entre nous c'est vous
monsieur X qui fixe le prix à telle date
à tel prix et moi qui dit non dans un
marché dans une clé de marché nous
sommes et que le marché c'est l'offre et
la demande augmenter la capacité
nucléaire de production d'électricité
nucléaire française augmenter la
fourniture l'offre et en augmentant
l'offre la demande sera inférieure à
l'offre et donc les prix baisseront
c'est ça la réalité parce qu'à chaque
fois que pour le coup on fait une
barrière administrative un jour vous
êtes rattrapé par les faits et ça marche
pas bon et c'est exactement à la reine
non mais alors après il y a le problème
du calendrier madame c'est c'est quel
moment et de la mesure mais c'est un
débat intéressant je ne dis pas qu'il y
a que de la vérité de mon côté
c'est pas très simple alors première
nécessité c'est pas un bien qui
appartient à tout le monde oh non quand
l'entreprise Danone a besoin
d'électricité pour faire fonctionner je
vois pas pourquoi c'est alors le
contribuable qui devrait payer
pour Danone après vous allez hurler sur
les dividendes pour les actionnaires
que je vais faire le pays a besoin d'une
fille à nucléaire pour produire
d'électricité augmentant notre capacité
de production d'écritée ces stratégique
et laissons les prix à l'offre et la
demande j'ajoute que vous êtes des gens
humaniste vous pouvez pas dire ce que
les Français font nous l'interdit aux
autres de le faire c'est trop simple
bon et enfin vous avez pris une
une
expression me permet de dire allégeance
aux Allemands ne jouez pas avec ça je
sais que c'est c'est
dans le mieux politique français dans
les pays ne change pas d'adresse
il déménage pas les pays
nous sommes voisins des Allemands ils
sont nos premiers clients nous sommes
leur premier fournisseur nous sommes
liés
si demain la France fait faillite
l'Allemagne est emporté
et c'est bien pour ça qu'en 2008 je l'ai
vu j'ai expliqué à Angela Markle
attention puisque la Grèce par terre
l'Italie était pas loin après l'Italie
c'était la France j'ai dit mais
torijouis pas trop parce que si la
France est emportée quand une entreprise
pardon la France est pas une entreprise
mais quand une collectivité une
entreprise perd son premier client
ça lui fait pas du bien on est lié
on est lié
et nous n'avons d'autres solutions
croyez-moi j'ai beaucoup réfléchi à ça
j'ai été élevé par mon grand-père qui a
fait deux guerres et qui n'aimaient pas
les Allemands et je vous dirai pas
comment il les appelait à la maison
c'est lui qui m'a élevé je sais très
bien comment les appelait et je me suis
promis de ne jamais en dire de mal parce
que ce n'est pas une question
d'allégeance entre nous
nous sommes voisins de l'Allemagne nous
avons une responsabilité alors je sais
très bien quand les Allemands les
Français sont d'accord ça exaspèrent
tout le monde mais quand on est en
désaccord ça panique tout le monde vaut
mieux exaspérer de paniquer bon et quand
le vent souffle et si demain il y a une
crise ou croyez moi on va pas chercher
Luxembourg on va pas chercher Malte je
sais très bien qui est responsable on a
beaucoup closé sur mercosi etc très bien
bon on était bien content de nous
trouver parce quand il fallait prendre
des paquets de mer peut dépendre donc
voilà ça j'aurai j'ai pas dans le sujet
excusez-moi maintenant mais quand même
et je suis tout à fait désolé que les
Allemands pour des raisons politiques
voire politiciennes n'ont pas fait le
même choix d'une clair que nous parce
que derrière tout ça il y avait
l'alliance avec les grenades des et la
stratégie vous savez allemande qui est
très différente puisque en Allemagne
vous ne lisez pas un homme ou une femme
vous les ayez un parti et c'est le chef
de sparti qui devient enfin c'est tout à
fait différent c'est il y avait l'homme
et la femme est élu mais après le parti
en profite bon pas comme ça
regardez mes amis
voilà c'est tout après l'énergie c'est
un débat passionnant parce que c'est au
cœur des des grands débats économiques
et politiques de la société française
c'est intéressant et on ne peut pas y
aller avec un une grille uniquement
écologique
idéologique idéologique
on doit trouver le passage dans des
économies modernes comment concilie la
nécessité d'un état stratège qui va
investir en dehors des forces du marché
et qu'on laisse le marché respirer pour
définir le prix qui permet à l'économie
française de vivre et au consommateurs
français de ne pas être écrasé c'est
plus facile à décrire qu'à faire mais
c'est quand même on est au cœur d'un
débat politique me semble-t-il noble et
intéressant
merci monsieur le Président alors pour
le modem
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le Président Sarkozy de votre
venue ici de vos propos liminaires qui
nous ont permis de constater que vous
n'avez rien perdu ni de votre verre ni
de votre sens de l'humour et c'est assez
agréable non mais tout est question
était à peu près posées sur l'arène nous
on a un avis un petit peu différent et
vous me direz si vous le partagez ou pas
c'est à dire que c'est bien facile de
critique de critiquer la reine
aujourd'hui mais je pense que pendant
des années tout le monde s'en est
satisfait tant que ça nous rapportait de
l'argent et effectivement la crise que
nous venons de vivre pose problème mais
je ne pense pas qu'il faille jeter le
bébé avec l'eau du bain donc ça
j'aimerais bien votre avis là-dessus et
deuxième question parce que je suis un
petit curieux vous avez parlé de
continuum au début de votre propos
liminaire entre les différents
présidents depuis les années 70 et donc
la mise en place de ce programme
d'énergie nucléaire
j'imagine qu'entre les présidents qui
étaient d'accord sur le sur le sur le
nucléaire ça ne posait pas de problème
au moment de la passation de pouvoir
avez-vous essayé d'en rediscuter avec le
président Hollande au moment où vous
êtes passé le pouvoir ou aviez-vous déjà
considérez que c'était peine perdue et
que la cause était entendue je vous
remercie
sur la reine je vous ai dit ce que j'en
pensais
je dis simplement au parlementaire vous
êtes avant de changer le système veillez
bien à ce que le nouveau je crois pas
pire que le précédent pardon de cette
remarque parce que quand on change les
équilibres attention bon je sais que
l'Europe travaille dessus on va voir ce
qu'il en sort je suis pas spécialement
confiant deuxièmement le président de la
République
durant lequel durant les mandats duquel
il y a eu le plus d'ouverture de
centrales c'est François Mitterrand
on peut dire tout ce qu'on veut vous
expliquer c'est ça c'est la vérité bon
donc quand on me dit que les socialistes
et contre le nucléaire c'est fou
François Mitterrand n'a jamais remis en
cause l'engagement nucléaire de la
France
jamais
absolument jamais et le revirement de la
du corpus idéologique des socialistes
c'est le moment où ils ont sont dit pour
gagner on a besoin d'une alliance avec
les écologistes
faut dire les choses comme ça c'est
vraiment l'opportunisme politique après
tout mais c'est c'est là bon
alors ce qui s'est passé la passation de
pouvoir avec Monsieur Hollande
on n'a pas parlé de grand chose
et je pense que
ça s'est vu puisque
je l'avais accueilli à sa voiture et je
crois qu'il m'a pas accompagné
ça vous montre je trahirai pas de secret
il y en a pas d'ailleurs mais
les choses
il aurait pu dire bon il y avait la
campagne pendant la campagne on dit des
bêtises et puis au lendemain de la
campagne
mais pas en cause mais je me souviens du
du texto
carillonnant de Madame Royal promesse
tenue au moment de la décision de fermer
un Fessenheim donc non seulement il y a
une erreur de conception il y a une
erreur d'exécution et il y a une erreur
dans le temps
c'est à dire que c'est pour reprendre la
belle expression d'André Santini ils ont
été dans le mur en klaxon
et je pense qu'il ne voulait rien
entendre rien écouter et
qu'on n'était pas dans quelque chose si
vous voulez de rationnel
comme après
Fukushima
c'était un nouveau Tchernobyl ça n'avait
rien à voir mais c'était pas rationnel
et très intéressant de voir
l'emballement médiatique d'ailleurs
comment le les anti-nucléaires est une
image extraordinaire je me souviens
d'une réunion à l'Élysée avec comment le
dernier candidat écologiste
Yannick
Jadot qui était à l'époque présidente de
son ONG et je lui disais venez au
Grenelle de l'environnement il y a le
il y avait la frontière du nucléaire
et qui ne reposait sur
aucun argument technique ou financier
je dirais que c'était presque esthétique
pour être moderne et je vous ai dit que
disait Martine Aubry et madame Joly sur
moi pour être moderne il fallait faire
moderne il y a rien de pire il y a rien
de pire vous savez
Pompidou a démodé de Gaulle
à démodé Pompidou
Chirac a des fleurs des
on peut pas dire à François Hollande
qu'il est démodé qui que ce soit mais
mais bon donc le manque d'avant le monde
d'avance si vous voulez
il ressemble comme une goutte d'eau
monte d'après
c'est toujours
les mêmes éléments sur la table et
d'ailleurs c'est assez réjouissant on a
les mêmes défauts que nous prédécesseurs
et nos successeurs auront les mêmes
qualités le même défaut ça implique à la
à la modestie mais c'était impossible
d'avoir un débat rationnel oui monsieur
de comme on a eu par exemple avec
le parlementaire tout à l'heure sur le
niveau de libéralisme le niveau de de
contre là on peut avoir un débat vous
voyez monsieur le Président sur le nuclé
alors je suis content que maintenant
votre commission on peut en parler sans
que ça provoque de drame et revenir
calmement mais
à l'époque faut que c'était un marqueur
vous êtes chez les modernes ou chez les
archaïques vous voyez c'était aussi
stupide que ça et je me souviens qu'en
mini stéta j'ai signé flamand ville
ni le Premier ministre ni le président
de la République n'ont souhaité se
porter en avant
ils étaient pas contre ils m'ont laissé
faire tout à fait il y a pas de j'ai
absolument aucun problème avec ça mais
porter le LEPR c'était pas quelque chose
qui qui ils m'ont vraiment laissé faire
vous voyez ce que je veux dire c'est il
faut comprendre qu'il y avait de
l'hystérie là-dedans bon je voudrais pas
lasser la commission mais merci quand
vous me relâcherez je partirai
pour le groupe socialiste madame
Baptiste
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la République
[Musique]
je vais être rapide vous avez parlé dans
votre avant-propos à peu près 45 minutes
et seulement
deux minutes des ENR et 43 minutes du
coup de du nucléaire je voulais
seulement rappeler que le titre de notre
commission c'est la perte de
souveraineté énergétique de la France et
que je considère que l'énergie c'est un
ensemble donc il y a effectivement le
nucléaire mais il y a également les
énergies renouvelables et d'ailleurs
vous l'avez dit à un moment dans votre
propos monsieur le Président que vous
considériez qu'il ne pouvait pas avoir
qu'une seule énergie et que
effectivement l'énergie renouvelable
était complémentaire donc c'est pour ça
que je m'étonne qu'on en est aussi peu
parlé et je vais me permettre d'en
parler peut-être un peu davantage
puisque l'ensemble de mes collègues sont
revenus à la fois sur ce qui a pu
fragiliser à un moment me semble-t-il la
notre entreprise
EDF c'est à dire la modification des
statuts la loi nomme la création de la
reine tout cela a été évoqué
et je considère aussi que si vous avez
parlé de 43 minutes de nucléaire c'est
que vous êtes profondément attaché au
nucléaire et je respecte tout à fait
cette position et je crois qu'en
politique le respect est de l'opinion de
l'autre est important on en manque
souvent et voilà ensuite je considère
aussi que ce que vous avez critiqué dans
le ce que vous appelez le l'accord écolo
PS de
2000 de 2012 c'est-à-dire la réduction
l'engagement de réduction de à 50% du
nucléaire ce n'est pas être
anti-nucléaire parce que 50% c'est une
part importante de notre énergie
également et on voit que aujourd'hui le
pluralisme de notre énergie est
également important au regard des
difficultés qu'on a connues qui qui à
mon avis ne sont imputables à personne
la corrosion sous contrainte personne ne
pouvait s'y attendre et à produit une
baisse extrêmement importante de notre
production dans l'année qui vient de
passer et je pense que fait ce name
aurait été ouvert ça n'aurait pas à
changer véritablement le cours du monde
à ce moment-là donc
voilà donc je reviendrai également sur
la question des des énergies
renouvelables puisqu'on en a pas parlé à
cette commission sur la décision que
vous aviez prise sur le moratoire du
photovoltaïque à un moment donné
d'autres personnes auditionnées nous ont
fait part que en nous disant ça marchait
trop bien donc il a fallu l'arrêter ça
coûtait trop d'argent je j'ai cru
comprendre ce que c'était donc le
mécanisme de tarif de de rachat qui
avait été posé au départ qui du coup
devenait très coûteux pour l'État
français mais au lieu de stopper cette
filière qui finalement tout le monde n'a
pu reprendre que trois ans plus tard et
donc à affaibli aussi notre capacité à
faire
est-ce que vous aviez réfléchi à ce
moment-là à modifier
les tarifs de d'achat comme on a fait
plus tard avec les compléments de
rémunération c'est-à-dire que quand les
prix de marché étaient plus hauts ont
baissé évidemment
et puis il y avait je crois aussi un
certain nombre de fraude qu'il a fallu
peut-être arrêter et c'était peut-être
l'objet de votre décision j'aimerais que
vous puissiez nous en dire un peu plus
sur ce sujet parce que je crois que ça a
quand même aussi stoppé et contribuer à
à la baisse de notre souveraineté en
tout cas
l'accélération pas suffisante de la
monter en puissance des ENR et la
dernière question à laquelle je tiens
beaucoup c'est celle de la question de
la décision de mise en concurrence des
centrales hydroélectriques qui a pris le
ministre Borlo sous votre sous votre
mandat qui nous a conduit à résister et
je fais partie des résistantes que
j'assume totalement puisque j'assume
aussi de n'être pas
libéral sur la question du marché de de
l'énergie puisque je considère que c'est
un bien important aujourd'hui un bien
nécessaire et qui ne doit pas être
traité comme un autre et donc ce qui
s'est passé dans les dernières années
les derniers mois nous montre que
effectivement on a on a besoin d'avoir
une souveraineté importante et ça passe
peut-être par un monopole de ça donc je
voudrais que vous m'expliquiez aussi ce
qui a pu conduire à céder aussi
facilement parce que à l'époque c'était
aussi facilement à la Commission
européenne qui je le rappelle n'avait
pas encore mis en demeure l'État
français ce qui a été peut-être fait un
tout petit peu plus tard
voilà sur ce sujet et puis le dernier
point c'est dans la construction de la
loi nomme sur laquelle je suis pas
favorable mais je respecte ce qu'ils ont
mis en place
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas à ce moment là
introduit dans la loi une obligation
pour les fournisseurs alternatifs de
faire de produire de l'électricité donc
de développer des outils de production
ce qui a été très peu fait très peu
contrôlés et je crois que vous aviez dit
à l'époque que c'était aussi pour créer
de grands champions et finalement on
constate aujourd'hui que on n'a pas
forcément créé de grands champions avec
ce dispositif puisqu'ils se sont plutôt
sourcés mais n'ont pas développé des
outils de production en tout cas jusqu'à
il y a très peu de temps puisque
aujourd'hui ça commence à se développer
merci beaucoup de vos réponses monsieur
le président
merci beaucoup madame de vos questions
c'est vrai j'ai moi parlé d'énergie
renouvelable
mon successeur aurait fermé une filière
d'énergie renouvelable ça n'aurait plus
parler
pourquoi parler de quelque chose qui
fonctionne il y a un consensus bon on
est passé quand même on est passé à 23%
optimiste souvenirs sont exacts de part
d'énergie renouvelable il n'y a pas de
débat aujourd'hui en France je connais à
part la question des éoliennes pour
d'autres raisons mais je ne connais
aucune force politique qui disent à tout
prix arrêtons les énergies renouvelables
il y en a pas donc dans la commission
c'est normal dans la politique qu'on
parle plus de ce qui fait débat que de
ce qui le fait pas c'est pas que je
m'intéresse pas aux énergies
renouvelables j'ai moi-même dans le
grand emprundi 1 € pour les énergies
renouvelables un Europôle nucléaire
c'était nouveau
le Grenelle de l'environnement c'était
énorme mais la fiscalité écologique je
l'ai voulue je l'ai fait voter par le
Parlement c'est le Conseil
constitutionnel
qu'il a annulé comme vous le savez donc
il y a pas trop matière à débattre des
énergies renouvelables parce qu'on est
tous d'accord sur les énergies
renouvelables qui viendrait dire aux
Français surtout pas d'énergie
renouvelable personne j'ai dit tout à
l'heure la différence entre les parties
du clair et partir du renouvelable c'est
que partie Jean du nucléaire dit il nous
faut du renouvelable absolument et les
partisans du renouvelable parfois disent
pas de nucléaire c'est absurde
vous me dites non non mais nous on
n'était pas
Antime clair on voulait juste se ramener
à 50%. heureusement que j'étais panthé
parce que qu'est-ce que ça serait si
vous l'aviez été
c'est un choix qui était extrêmement
lourd alors
le photovoltaïque après je suis pas là
c'est la commission bon quel est le
problème du photovoltaïque problème
photovoltaïque c'est le stockage
d'ailleurs problème éternel de
l'électricité c'est que ça stoppe pas
voilà
vous avez avec le photovoltaïque et
c'est pas monsieur le Président
remettent en cause le photovoltaïque ou
monsieur le rapporteur que dire ça c'est
un problème photovoltaïque produite
l'électricité de l'énergie quand vous en
avez pas besoin en été et en plein jour
insulter personne c'est simplement
réfléchir avec sa tête et comme ça
stocke pas ou très difficilement
si vous comptez que sur le
photovoltaïque et que vous êtes dans un
petit pays ou climat tempéré ça marche
pas
ou c'est décevant en tout cas regardez
les batteries électriques qui s'est
passé si ça marchait ça ne saurait donc
j'étais bien obligé de dire parce que
oui madame député excusez-moi énergir
renouvelable c'est un concept dans
lequel il y a plusieurs maisons
et toutes les maisons de se valent pas
j'ai toujours pensé c'est vrai que
l'éolien hopshore était plus prometteur
que le photovoltaïque pour la raison du
climat français et des difficultés de
stockage j'ajoute un autre problème
c'est que moi un moment j'en ai eu assez
on faisait marcher que les Chinois
on subventionné à fond
à fond
et on faisait venir de Chine tous les
panneaux je n'ai un peu assez gilet
est-ce qu'on peut pas utiliser mettez
voir à ma place un peu différemment
l'argent vous
il y a un petit côté sur ce qui fait que
votre commission est passionnante c'est
qu'il y a un petit côté sacré religieux
enfin je veux dire les gens rentrent
dans le débat avec des des idées bon
renouvelable renouvelable une fois que
vous avez dit mais pas vous madame
excusez-moi je vous montre pas de
respect mais une fois qu'on pose le
tampon énergie renouvelable c'est bien
non réfléchis bon le photovoltaïque
coûtait de plus en plus cher et ça
partait favorisée pour les entreprises
chinoises à un moment donné je me suis
dit peut-être que on pourrait penser à
développer chez nous
et
l'éolien offshore me permettait d'avoir
une énergie enfin permettait qu'on ait
une énergie nationale et sans les
problèmes de dénaturation des paysages
encore que là aussi disons les choses
comme ils sont je porte ma part de
responsabilité mais j'ai vu le parc
offshore
Saint-Nazaire enfin au large de sur le
de la côte sauvage il y a des endroits
où quand même moi j'ai expliqué que
c'était grand comme une allumette ça
fait une grosse allumette
bon faut avoir l'honnêteté quand même de
reconnaître que
l'éolien y compris l'éolien offshore
parce que l'éolien sort vous le mettez
pas au plein milieu de l'océan il faut
quand même trouver des rochers sur
lequel vous mettez ces petites centrales
et éoliennes et même à 12 km comme celle
dont ce parc dont je parle ça pose ça
pose un certain nombre de questions bon
sur les centrales hydroélectriques
vous avez reçu
Monsieur Borlo il a dû vous répondre on
n'avait pas effectivement reçu la mise
en demeure mais c'est pas parce qu'on
l'avait pas reçu qui nous avait pas
téléphoné quand je savais pas ce qu'il
en était
et se mettre en demeure j'avais pas non
plus envie que la France soit condamnée
dans le contexte dans lequel nous nous
trouvions
non mais tant mieux tant mieux je le
souhaite pas bon
donc c'est pas le problème des centrales
hydroélectriques je me suis pas
occupé tellement que ça mais voilà voilà
ce que j'en sais pour moi
le futur des énergies renouvelables je
vous le dis comme je le pense avec
modestie
la terre devrait s'appeler la mère
puisque 60% de la surface de la planète
c'est de l'eau
or il se trouve que 4 fois par jour 60%
de la planète avant ces recul
et je pense que là on a une source
d'énergie potentielle
inépuisable
avec les problèmes sur lequel on
travaille dans cette usine fantastique
qui est l'usine Marie motrice de la
Rance que j'ai visité plusieurs fois qui
est extrêmement intéressant on n'arrive
pas ou très difficilement à faire des
métaux qui résistent au sel
et par ailleurs si on mettait des
turbines dans dans la mer les courants
les marais sont pas toujours assez
régulières pour bon et je pense
également que le froid
le froid est une énergie et que dans les
grands fonds il y a beaucoup d'énergie
moi je crois beaucoup
à cela et je pense que si j'avais des
responsabilités aujourd'hui je mettrai
beaucoup d'argent dans la recherche sur
la mer ou les océans comme production
énergétique beaucoup plus pour moi avec
la modestie je suis pas ingénieur bien
sûr que le photovoltaïque dont je vois
que malgré les milliards investis on a
beaucoup de mal à organiser le stockage
de cette énergie bon alors je j'ai vu
les débats sur les voitures électriques
vous voyez comme les choses changent
rapidement c'est intéressant quand même
devoir se parier le nucléaire maintenant
une majorité pour ils étaient majorité
des comptes mais les voitures
électriques je vous le dis le débat de
fait commencer et vous verrez que ça
changera au niveau européen parce que là
aussi le coût des voitures électriques
un certain nombre de ménages aux revenus
plus modestes ne pourront pas y accéder
et par ailleurs je conteste l'idée que
c'est des politiques qui définissent
quelle est la bonne filière plutôt
quelle est la mauvaise parce que
investir massivement dans la voiture
électrique c'est ce priver d'autres
technologies qui pourraient elle aussi
prometteuse pour l'avenir
merci Madame
si alors madame Besse et puis ensuite je
propose de prendre les questions en
série parce que je ne voudrais pas
abuser du temps leur avançant
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le Président de la République
vous a répondu à de très nombreuses
questions c'était fort intéressant moi
j'ai une question concernant l'éolien
très rapidement vous en avez parlé dans
votre propos liminaire quels ont été à
l'époque les raisons qui vous ont poussé
à à développer l'éolien et notamment
l'éolien offshore vous avez évoqué un
parc que je connais bien puisque le Pays
de la Loire je suis député de la Vendée
donc l'épée de la Loire je connais bien
ça fait polémique aujourd'hui l'éolien
en mer quels ont été à l'époque les
raisons qui vous ont poussé à développer
l'éolien
très simple nous avons la Manche nous
avons aussi Atlantique nous avons la
Méditerranée nous sommes une puissance
maritime donc il me semblait que c'était
important politiquement d'utiliser ce
potentiel
naturellement si j'étais avait été
premier ministre de Hongrie j'aurais pas
choisi l'éolien offshore mais nous
sommes un pays qui a une superficie
maritime considérable deuxièmement alors
pour le coup madame politiquement je
sentais monter la polémique
sur l'éolien
sur site et j'avais notamment le
président Giscard d'Estaing qui était
déchaîné contre l'implantation d'un parc
éolien là dans les châteaux de la Loire
et je m'étais dit
essayons l'éolien offshore ça éloigne le
bruit ça éloigne les nuisances visuelles
et on profite de notre dimension
océanographique pour le faire ça aurait
été fou de pas le faire donc c'est j'ai
je l'assume j'ai essayé d'être honnête
même parce que quand j'ai annoncé moi
j'adore cette région notamment la route
de l'océan c'est une des plus belles qui
soient et
vraiment je me suis préoccupé de de cela
et
je dois dire que j'ai un peu sous-estimé
la nuisance visuelle voilà mais le but
de l'éolienne j'y crois
et j'ai dit mais pourquoi vous le mettez
pas plus loin
et de ce kilomètre quand même c'est pas
rien de tout ce kilomètre parce que là
il y a il y avait vous connaissez la
région des rochers et et des au fond et
on pouvait installer les centrales c'est
là où j'ai compris qu'on que c'était pas
comme les vous savez les les plateformes
pétrolières avec des pieds là qui qui
que vous mettez provisoirement il
fallait qu'on s'appuie sur quelque chose
mais c'était vraiment un choix politique
qui correspondait à la géographie de
notre pays et en plus je trouvais que
c'était impossible de nous couper de
cette source d'énergie renouvelable pour
le coup je pouvais pas dire le
photovoltaïque se fait les Chinois le
nucléaire bon on y va le solaire on a du
mal à stocker les éoliennes il y avait
les pour les comptes et je comprends que
vous êtes sous une hâte c'est quand même
pas très marrant et pas faire leur
offshore donc pour moi ça me semble
évident
c'est une décision précédente la
République aussi parce que pardon ça
engage tellement le paysage et
l'écosystème que
c'est pas une décision que peut prendre
seul dans un coin enfin pas un coin
excusez-moi le ministre de
l'Environnement ou le ministre de
l'Industrie c'est vraiment il faut
engager et d'ailleurs regarder il a
fallu trois présidents de la République
pour que ça sorte entre la décision que
j'ai prise et l'inauguration par le
président Macron il est très président
merci beaucoup alors je vais prendre du
coup les séries de questions
monsieur Loubet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la République Nicolas
Sarkozy merci pour cette audition
j'aurai quatre questions à vous poser
deux sur des points de désaccord deux
autres sur pour obtenir des
éclaircissements tout d'abord pourquoi
avez-vous défendu comme chef de l'État
et continuez-vous à défendre le marché
européen de l'énergie qui aujourd'hui
nous rend en termes de prix dépendant
des prix du gaz alors même que
l'alliance du nucléaire et de
l'hydraulique of et offrait et continue
d'offrir à la France un prix
particulièrement compétitif parmi les
plus compétitifs d'Europe et excusez moi
mais dans votre réponse que vous avez
apporté à Monsieur jumelles tout à
l'heure vous avez parlé effectivement du
couple franco-allemand j'entends
toujours est-il que à aujourd'hui et
c'était déjà le cas sous votre président
le couple se fait malheureusement
souvent je dirais de manière asymétrique
aujourd'hui je crois que le déficit
commercial de la France à l'égard de
l'Allemagne en témoigne près de 14
milliards d'euros de déficits
commerciales donc à mes yeux la question
de la de la préservation des bonnes
relations avec l'Allemagne n'est pas
valable si ce n'est à la limite faire de
la France le dindon de la farce et ce
marché européen de l'énergie aujourd'hui
est en train de ruiner notre économie et
nous finances publiques c'est une
véritable perte de souveraineté en
matière d'énergie deuxième question
encore sur les pointes des accords vous
avez mis en place le système donc de
l'arène en 2011 nous en avons beaucoup
parlé et je souhaite revenir dessus ce
système donc impose EDF de vendre 25% de
sa production à des fournisseurs
alternatifs l'objectif c'était de
limiter les prix de l'énergie en créant
artificiellement par la loi finalement
de la concurrence donc vous nous avez
effectivement exposé votre amour de la
concurrence mais forter de constater
aujourd'hui avec du recul monsieur le
Président que et bien ce site cette
politique cette décision a échoué elle a
échoué parce que les prix de l'énergie
ont augmenté encore une fois alors que
la France était parmi les pays les plus
compétitifs elle a échoué parce que vous
aviez annoncé effectivement la création
de champion énergétique français et
qu'aujourd'hui on se rend compte que
nous avons tout un tas de fournisseurs
que les Français ne connaissent pas
forcément et que le principal champion
industriel de l'énergie que EDF et se
retrouve plus que jamais affaibli
d'autant plus que un tiers de la dette
du groupe EDF et directement lié à la
reine troisième question donc je ne
comprends pas du coup comment vous
pouvez continuer à défendre ce système
là d'autant plus si je me trompe pas que
il devrait normalement s'achever en tout
cas quand il avait été mis en place en
2011 en 2026 puisque ça durait de vie
était d'environ 15 ans
troisième question concernant le père de
Flamanville que vous aviez donc lancé en
2004 en tant que ministre de l'Industrie
comment est-ce que vous expliquez
l'imprévoyance des acteurs industriels
et donc évidemment de l'État mais
effectivement des acteurs industriels
quand dérapage de coûts et de délai que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui nous sommes
en 2023 le chantier de vie durée 7 ans
et le réacteur n'est toujours pas
démarré et actuellement nous vous savez
sans doute nous sommes en train
d'examiner un projet de loi sur la
relance du nucléaire et le gouvernement
veut faire le choix de PR de deuxième
génération qui sont des EPR qui se base
donc sur un design virtuel et ma
question synthétique s'il vous plaît oui
tout à fait mais j'en suis même pas 3
minutes donc ma question est monsieur le
Président Sarkozy est-ce que au regard
du retour d'expérience finalement de ces
dérapages en termes de délai et de coûts
sur le père de Flamanville est-ce que
vous ne pensez pas que dans le cadre du
projet de loi actuelle on ne devrait pas
se mettre plutôt à construire les
premières séries de réacteurs sur le Pr
première génération dont nous maîtrisons
désormais l'expérience et la maîtrise
technologique plutôt que se lancer sur
une nouvelle technologie et risquer de
d'être confronté au même problème qu'il
y a eu pour le père de Flamanville
dernière question succincte monsieur le
Président je souhaiterais vous
interroger sur les enjeux énergétiques
qui ont entouré la guerre en Libye on en
n'avons pas parlé la Libye exportée en
2010 plus de 10% de sa production
d'hydrocarbures en France 14 % en
Allemagne ont encore 30% vers l'Italie
donc l'Europe était effectivement un de
ses premiers débouchés en termes
d'exportation d'hydrocarbures et je
souhaiterais que vous nous éclairciiez
sur et bien la manière dont vous avez
anticipé avant de prendre la décision
d'engager les forces militaires
françaises donc vous avez anticipé la
sécurité d'approvisionnement en termes
d'hydrocarbures de la France mais aussi
de l'Europe je suppose avec vos
partenaires européens je crois que ce
sont des enjeux intéressants étant donné
que les marchés ont temporairement en
tout cas été déstabilisés en termes de
prix du baril je vous remercie
monsieur des cœurs
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président de la République
vous avez dans votre propos introductif
rappelé un épisode de la campagne
présidentielle de 2007 ou à l'invitation
d'un animateur de petit écran pour
reprendre votre expression vous avez eu
l'occasion de d'affirmer avec force
votre position sur nucléaire devant les
ONG
s'agissant de ces ONG moi j'aimerais
regarder l'expérience qui est la vôtre
vous puissiez nous nous éclairer sur
l'action qui était la leur vous avez pu
mesurer au cours de votre mandat et en
particulier au lendemain Fukushima et je
souhaiterais aussi recueillir votre avis
sur l'influence qui a pu être la leur
dans les décisions qui sont intervenues
au lendemain de votre mandat et qui ont
mis un mal notre filière nucléaire
alors
vous me rappelez un jeune député que
j'ai bien connu
qui parle avec beaucoup de force et qui
croyaient que la force remplaçait la
vigueur des arguments
c'était de moi dont il s'agissait
j'espère que on vous comparant à moi je
ne vous ai pas blessé en tout cas de mon
point de vue c'était flatteur
je vais essayer je vais vous répondre
naturellement mais je vais essayer de on
va pas revenir si le Président nous a
dit c'est pas un débat c'est des
questions mais quand même moi je crois
au marché européen pour une raison
simple vous le découvrirez c'est que les
Européens sont nos premiers clients
et vous allez voir que le brexit est une
catastrophe absolue d'abord pour eux
parce que vous ne pouvez pas vous couper
de vos premiers clients
et si vous croyez que vous pouvez tout
prendre sur la table et rien donné aux
autres c'est que vous êtes au début de
votre carrière politique et donc vous
n'avez pas d'expérience parce que ça ne
marche pas comme ça donc le marché
européen j'y crois et le marché européen
vous pouvez pas dire il y a marché
européen pour tout ce qui m'arrange mais
il y a pas marché européen parce qu'il
m'arrange pas ça ça existe pas bon vous
vivez dans un monde avec des voisins
je vous dire une chose
l'Europe de tous les continents du monde
et le continent le plus brutal où il y a
eu les guerres les plus sauvages c'est
pas l'Afrique c'est pas l'Asie c'est
l'Europe et je vais vous dire autre
chose c'est pas au Moyen-Âge c'est au
20e siècle
c'est en Europe qu'on exterminer des
Juifs
c'est en Europe qu'on s'est battu
quand on a dit avec la guerre Russo
Ukraine c'est le retour de la guerre
qu'on avait pas vu c'est une stupidité
puisqu'on a oublié la Bosnie
si vous n'avez pas l'Union européenne
vous avez des affrontements
considérables
et vous savez dans la politique il faut
avoir des engagements vous avez du
tempérament faut connaître l'histoire
et l'histoire donne une dimension à vos
engagements une couleur à vos
engagements
vous êtes pas simplement le produit d'un
parti politique ou d'une famille vous
êtes reproduit d'une nation et d'un
continent notre continent est brutal
sauvage et peuvent verser dans la
barbarie
c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé
nos prédécesseurs de construire un
modèle d'union fondé sur quoi sur le
marché
la paix en Europe est fondée sur le
nos pays avaient été ravagés par la
guerre on a décidé de produire ensemble
de l'acier et du charbon
c'est le marché qui a fait la paix
et ne pas comprendre ça
c'est un peu théorique
deuxième élément
sur l'Allemagne on est le dindon de la
farce
c'est facile de dire ça et ça n'a aucun
sens je vais vous dire mieux quand
j'étais plus jeune
tout le monde vous n'êtes pas le centre
du monde réfléchissez plus
vous avez beaucoup de talents beaucoup
de force et ça m'est sympathique prenez
de l'épaisseur ne dites pas ça c'est
faux je dis pas ça parce que vous êtes
rassemblement national mais vous savez
je respecte toutes les opinions et après
tout Madame Le Pen a voté pour Londres
on a le droit d'avoir fait des erreurs
dans la vie
donc c'est pour dire je suis pas
d'accord avec toi avec vous vous aussi
oui oui bon et donc bon mais ne parlez
pas comme ça du couple franco-allemand
c'est trop grave c'est trop important
un peu comme nucléaire en plus important
il faut mesurer ça parce que des gens
sont morts quand on dit la deuxième
guerre mondiale c'est fou il y en a eu
trois
parce que les gens de territoire Belfort
exactement et
ils savent parfaitement ce qui ce qu'il
en était trois fois donc
excusez-moi je peux pas vous suivre
là-dessus alors vous dites votre amour
de la concurrence vous êtes convertis
vous êtes converti au communisme tant
mieux l'amour la concurrence je suis pas
du tout en théoricien je pense que de
tous les systèmes économiques qui ont
été ne
essayez les collines marchés et le
meilleur je suis pas le seul à le penser
il faut quand même être totalement
aveugle pour pas comprendre ça alors
vous je vois bien il faut
tout est bon dans le cochon alors Alban
mon amour la concurrence il y a quoi mon
amour la concurrence oui je crois que la
concurrence vous savez je crois
l'émulation je crois qu'on mérite c'est
pour ça que la France populaire m'a
écouté je crois l'immulation au mérite
et elle vaut quoi l'émulation le
méritent il y a pas de la concurrence si
c'est toujours les mêmes qui ont la même
chose c'est que vous travaillez que vous
travaillez pas la même chose oh revoyez
votre votre
classique bon alors sur le père et
des dérapages oui bien sûr bien sûr mais
enfin je vous rappelle que les Chinois
qui sont connus pour être bien organisés
avec d'autres concepts ils ont eu aussi
les dérapages je vous l'ai dit c'est une
nouvelle technologie c'est pas
simplement parce qu'on est tous des
imbéciles et je suis sûr qu'il y a un
jour c'était vous alors vous vous êtes
capable de diriger le Pr de voir que ça
marche impeccablement qu'il n'y a pas de
dérapage qui a rien du tout bon bah oui
diriger LEPR c'est pas diriger montre
tout c'est un peu plus compliqué encore
que là aussi bon alors oui oui mais je
réponds
je sais quand on me cherche ou quand
vous me trouvez ça vous donne ne faites
pas votre angélique c'est pas être
désagréable que de vous dire ça au
contraire je pourrais dire je réponds
pas j'ai pas entendu bon alors vous
m'avez interrogé sur la Libye édition
mais c'est pas une question française
monsieur la grande différence entre la
décision de George Bush en Irak et la
décision sur la Libye vous savez
laquelle c'est c'est une décision du
conseil de la pardon de l'Assemblée
générale des Nations unies nous avions
un mandat
il y avait un mandat attention quand
monsieur bouche va
en Irak il y a pas de mandat
quand la coalition de 53 pays
vend les Libye et un mandat officiel
officiel de l'Assemblée générale des
Nations unies peut-être qu'il y a des
dysfonctionnements mais ça compte ça
fonctionne
et puis pour le reste la politique c'est
la politique et je vous souhaite la
carrière la plus vibrante qui soit
sur les ONG
c'est très curieux ce qui s'est passé
pourquoi les responsables politiques
n'ont pas une bonne image médiatique et
pourquoi les dirigeants d'ONG ont une
image favorable et là ça concerne
absolument tous les
toutes les formations politiques je
trouve ça juste
les dirigeants d'ONG restent à la tête
de le réseau NG sans personne leur
demande de compte bien souvent les
dirigeants politiques
vous pouvez battus c'est clair
on y va à découvert
et
malgré ça les dirigeants politiques sont
très souvent critiqués injustement
critiquées
la précarité
d'autant plus avec le la règle du nom
cumulité mandats
et
sur le un plateau médiatique si vous
êtes sur une ONG vous êtes considéré
comme plus représentatif que si vous
êtes élu d'une circonscription membre du
Parlement je n'aime pas ça je vous le
dis très franchement j'aime pas ça ça
veut pas dire que je n'aime pas la
discussion avec les ONG puisque comme
vous le savez je les ai mis sur le cœur
dans dans
Grenelle de l'environnement mais pour
moi la souveraineté populaire elle est
celle du Parlement et du président de la
République
et en aucun cas du mouvement associatif
le mouvement associatif est extrêmement
important extrêmement généreux je n'ai
rien à dire là-dessus mais excusez-moi
le peuple s'exprime au travers des
parlementaires qui soit de gauche de
droite du rassemblement national peu
importe et une fois pour ça que moi j'ai
jamais compris pourquoi on disait il y a
un pacte vous êtes élu vous faites
partie de la République si vous n'étiez
pas
républicain on vous laisserait pas vous
présenter bon et chez les Français vous
envoient et ouais
cette question là de la de la différence
d'image
nous devrions me semble-t-il y penser
tous je vois des représentants de
d'Angers
prendre la parole tout le temps
et
des parlementaires quelque soit leur
engagement politique être mis en bout de
plateau à qui on donne avec des
pincettes la parole et oui mais vous
vous êtes un politique et alors c'est
mano blesse et alors ça vaut quand même
autre chose cette politique il faut se
présenter aux élections faut être battu
j'ai pas un centimètre moi de mon corps
il y a pas de psychiatrice on n'a pas
volé la place
donc oui oui c'est un grand problème et
votre commission peut participer à la
résolution du parti du problème en
mettant des gens différents femmes et
hommes à discuter ensemble
et à produire un rapport sérieux qui n'a
d'autre objectifs que de tutoyer la
vérité et non pas de chercher un effet
d'image voilà je je le dis pour tous les
représentants ici des formations
politiques quels qu'ils soient
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président de
la République je vous remercie très
sincèrement
ceux qui ont voulu poser question on
peut les poser
je vous remercie très sincèrement pour
les
deux heures écart que 2h03/4 que vous
avez consacré je crois que c'est une
première le président de la République
n'est pas responsable d'un point de vue
de la constitution devant le Parlement
et vous avez néanmoins accepté de
répondre à notre invitation pour venir
partager avec nous la façon dont vous
avez perçu ce sujet de l'énergie au plus
haut niveau de l'État qui est bien
niveau stratégique qui est pas au niveau
de la tuyauterie de détails tel que vous
l'avez précisé merci parce que votre
éclairage nous sera utile merci pour
votre verbe et l'expérience que vous
avez partagé avec nous puis je vous
remercie vous parce que ça m'a donné un
coup de jeune quand même
et je voudrais que vous compreniez quand
terminant que pour moi
la politique m'a tellement apporté j'ai
essayé de lui donner mais tellement
porté que
je n'aime pas l'idée de c'était mieux
avant
mon devoir c'est aussi de participer à
ça et de rencontrer les les nouveaux
élus c'était un plaisir d'avoir cet
échange je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président